Boom,
and we're live.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Heather hiring Bret Weinstein.
I didn't screw it up this time.
Nope,
you got it right.
God,
I get that.
Steen,
stine thing messed up with you again.
I apologize.
Just a bad time to get those messed up.
So thanks for having us.
Thank you for being here.
Both of you.
I'm very excited about this
conversation.
Really excited about it.
Too.
Little bit nervous in one way,
but,
but pretty,
pretty jazzed.
Well,
I think it's good to be nervous about
it.
You know what I mean,
what we're talking about folks,
what we would like to talk about is why
don't you explain it?
Well,
uh,
I think,
and heather and I have been on an
interesting adventure.
We are evolutionary biologists.
We trained with some of the finest
evolutionary biologists of the 20th
century and we have been teaching.
We taught for habitat for 15 years.
I taught for 14 years at Evergreen and
we spent a lot of time,
uh,
dealing with students and trying to help
them see how clarifying and evolutionary
viewpoint is with respect to
understanding what a human being is and
how we functioned and how we interact.
And that was very enjoyable to us and it
was very empowering to students to
discover that there was actually a way
of removing a lot of the confusion of
being a,
a person and we're now watching the
conversation out in civilization about
sex and gender devolve into an
absurdity.
And on the one hand that's kind of
frightening.
I mean for,
for,
for us,
it's not directly an issue were happily
married.
And so what we're not having to navigate
romance out in the world these days.
And our kids are too young to be
navigating it.
Yet maybe this will all be clarified by
the time they're involved in dating.
But we also have a tremendous number of
millennial friends,
former students who are trying to
navigate this stuff and finding it
difficult and bewildering to hear a
conversation that frankly,
there's a,
a much better alternative.
If one can stand to think in
evolutionary terms,
if we can really look at ourselves as we
are,
as we came to be through evolutionary
forces than actually we can improve the
landscape for romance and dating a great
deal,
but we can't do it if we're committed to
very simple truisms that actually
aren't.
Right.
What
is disturbing both of you most about
what's going on right now?
Well,
I think we'd love to see a third way.
So they're the pre moderns as it were,
have very traditionalist conservative
that sucker up.
Close to say that.
No worries.
Yeah,
perfect.
The premodern.
So you have a very traditional
conservative approach to gender roles,
to sex,
to relationship.
And uh,
there are a lot of us
in the modern world who would reject a
lot of that.
And then there are the postmoderns who
want to throw out everything.
I want to throw out everything that
evolution handed us.
And in the meantime,
pretend that it didn't happen,
right?
Pretend that it's not even based on
reality and there is a,
there's a third way and you know,
maybe we need to call it modern as
opposed to pre or postmodern,
but uh,
there's,
there's a third way to navigate what
evolutionary is,
what evolution has given us,
what we can change,
what we can't change,
and how to actually recover some of,
you know,
the sexiness and sex and the love and
love and the romance and romance and you
know,
understand that human beings are what we
are from not just 100 years back,
but a thousand and $10,000
100 million years back.
We've had sex
since you both taught at a university
level,
you,
you've been around these students and
you've seen this sort of postmodernist
movement gained steam.
What,
what do you think is the cause of it?
Like what?
What is the reason why people are
projecting this sort of distorted idea?
That there's no differences between men
and women and that all the differences
in the genders are all.
It's all propaganda or cultural or.
So I think it actually arises from a
relatively simple cause that we all
detect there's something not right about
what we've been taught.
We detect there's something not right
about the way civilization is
structured.
We can tell that there's nobody really
at the helm and you have a lot of people
who are faced with some issue that to
them is incredibly glaring.
Something that just absolutely needs to
be solved.
And so what they do is they look at that
issue and they say,
what would we have to,
what would we have to say in order for
that issue to be fully addressed?
And the problem is that we're dealing
with a complex system and if you
optimize for any one solution,
you cause a catastrophe across all of
the other things that it's connected to.
And if you're not focused on those
unintended consequences,
you tend not to understand why people
are resistant to your solution.
So for example,
let's deal with the transgender issue
for the transgender community,
and I don't know,
this is not a monolith community.
I actually know quite a number of people
within it who have a heterodox position.
But in general,
there's a sense that it is disrespectful
not to simply recognize anybody who has
decided to transition as a full fledged
member of the sex to which they have
moved.
That seems right.
And if you are focused on,
uh,
the humanitarian side of the question,
maybe it even is right?
But the problem is if you say a person
who identifies as a particular sex is
that sex suddenly you've actually caused
a whole bunch of consequences that you
weren't thinking of over in a biology
class over a,
in the prison system.
I mean,
is it true that somebody who says that
they are female gets to go to a women's
prison?
Do we want to put a violent sex
offenders in a women's prison because
they declare themselves to be female?
So not tracking the consequences that
were not in your view when you decided
on a particular solution is the reason
that so many people have signed up for
these really absurd notions.
And part of what I hope we will get to
today is that there is a,
a principal at the core of understanding
all complex adaptive systems.
And it is diminishing returns and
diminishing returns sounds kind of
arcane.
Um,
it has to close in association with
economics where it was first outlined.
But the message of diminishing returns
is that you can very often get 90
percent of a solution that you want and
not disrupt other things unduly.
But if you say,
I want a hundred percent of the solution
to this problem,
you'll cause a catastrophe.
So getting people to realize don't shoot
for the Utopia in which the problem
you're talking about is 100 percent
solved.
If you can accept a 90 percent solution,
then you can have a whole bunch of other
things that you don't even realize
you're using
in defense of people that would try to
go for 100 percent though,
isn't it one of those things where like
you,
if you would negotiate,
you would.
If you want $100 you asked for 150.
Unfortunately.
I mean,
I think you're identifying something,
correct that in part the positions that
we hear being deployed are not an honest
reflection of the beliefs of many of the
people who are espousing them.
They're a negotiating tactic,
but we can't do that with biology.
You can't negotiate with biology.
Biology is what it is,
and then we can talk about which parts
of it are amenable to being changed.
And as heather pointed out,
we're not advocating for a return to
some traditional way of interacting
between the sexes.
We're advocating for,
uh,
an enlightened way that takes advantage
of the freedom that we have that our
ancestors didn't and tries to navigate
the hazards that were stuck with.
So you can't,
you can't negotiate with biology.
You're really ought to listen to what it
is that nature is telling you.
And then say,
all right,
what does that leave open?
Where can we shift things?
But if you're going to require that,
we lie about what's true biologically in
order to navigate to a solution,
I guarantee you it will be unstable in
the end.
Yeah.
The site guys to speak gun to include
such nonsense as chromosomes exist on a
continuum.
You know,
their x chromosomes and there a y
chromosome.
I haven't heard that one.
One of our children just heard that his
school,
what did they mean by on a continuum?
Who even knows?
I don't think they meant anything.
I think what they intended to do was
carve out freedom from a biological
truth,
and so if you say chromosomes are on a
continuum,
then it's very hard to disagree with
that because it doesn't mean anything
that we can say.
It's actually really easy to disagree
with it and say,
no,
no.
Gametes aren't on a continuum.
Sperm,
sperm and eggs are eggs.
Sorry.
Discreet to have them.
Right.
Chromosomes also not on a continuum,
at least in mammals.
Sex,
yeah,
a continuum.
They're Intersex is real,
but it's strongly by model,
right?
There's.
There are males and females and there
are a few people.
It's rare,
but real that there are intermediate
phenotypes and gender is even more of a
continuum,
but still strongly by modal.
Have you folks heard about that?
New crayfish that they're battling in
Europe,
there's a giant crayfish in Europe
that's female and female only and
essentially is a clone.
They.
They reproduced by cloning so they don't
need a male partner and they're going
crazy and there's a lot of them.
For your first two sentences there,
it sounded like there was a giant
sending on Europe.
It was a female.
She's mad,
she's tired.
All these lobster dinners and that's
going to work for a while.
Right,
and like asexuality is actually evolved
in a few lineages,
a few vertebrate lenses.
There's some lizards that are asexual
and it's all females and it goes great
until the environment changes because if
you're cloning yourself,
you,
your children are going to experience
exactly are going to be exactly the same
thing that you were.
So if you were a good fit for your
environment,
the next environment better be the same
or else your kids aren't going to be a
good fit.
So my feeling is that crayfish,
I haven't followed the story a lot,
but that crayfish is going to do
terrifically moving into exactly the
landscapes that it first mutated into
existence in.
And if you change the landscape of bed,
it's gonna stop doing.
So I think they just farm it for food if
it's tasty.
Yeah,
no worry about them breathing and get a
ton of home together.
Crayfish are delicious.
They are delicious.
This is a good tasting variety.
It's free food.
I know.
It's kind of crazy.
So heather and I were talking before the
podcast started about over,
I think a very important point when it
comes to a lot of these,
uh,
either progressive or right wing issues
is that people tend to be extremely
tribal and what they're really concerned
with is winning.
It becomes a competition of US versus
them.
It becomes our side versus their side
and they tend to exploit weaknesses and
then attack to score points and all the
ideas of being honest intellectually or
looking at things objective,
kind of go out the window.
You ignore facts that diminished your
position or your team's position and
highlight things even if they're not
real.
That would diminish the other side's
position.
This is a real problem that humans have
with arguments with,
with being tribal,
with being on different sides.
I mean,
we see it,
we forget about tribes.
We see with people where when there's a
certain time,
when you see people arguing,
there's a certain point where the
argument has deteriorated to a
competition and it's no longer about
what you're actually discussing.
It's about who can win sciences for.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well this is
science ought to be indifferent.
When it's done well,
it is indifferent to who's the stronger
team.
It should really just tell you what's
true and in fact the reason to use
sciences to correct for biases,
but so eric and heather and I have a
phrase that is just shorthand for
something which is bad.
Faith changes everything.
There's a lot you can do in discussion
with people with whom you disagree as
long as you are on the same page to a
large extent and what you're describing
is what happens when that system breaks
down and people perceive themselves as
needing to win against the enemy rather
than on a team that is trying to
navigate to what is true or what is the
most desirable outcome with respect to
values that we all share or something
like that.
So what you're describing is a very
common state.
It is a lower,
less capable state than a good faith
environment where people who may
disagree intensely agree on the basic
rules and the desirability of figuring
out what's true and so maybe that's part
of what we can do here is try to point
to where the good faith conversation can
get to that.
The bad faith conversation is incapable
of getting to the value really daily.
Yeah,
I think that's a giant point.
It really is,
and it's A.
I mean,
if it's really something that I would
hope more people would adopt going into
the future,
stop connecting yourself to these ideas
and just let these ideas exist on their
own and they examined them objectively
and rely on science.
Rely on actual science to formulate
your.
When you're talking about biological
issues,
when I say science is the answer to
this,
it's not necessarily that we should
accept.
No one should accept the findings of
science just at face value,
but a scientific approach is I've gotten
this idea what would have to be true if
that were true and how can I possibly
prove it wrong and you work harder and
harder and harder to prove it wrong,
and if you can't then you have greater
and greater and greater confidence that
maybe it's right and so this,
this is what we don't say in bad faith.
Arguments is no one is trying to prove
themselves wrong and that's,
I mean that sounds backwards the first
time you hear it,
but if you try to actually demonstrate
that your own cherished beliefs are
wrong and you can't do it,
you have pretty good confidence at the
end of that and there is no actual end,
but the longer you've gone,
you have pretty good confidence that
actually I'm probably seeing real here.
I've asked myself,
I've asked,
my friends,
have asked my enemies,
is this thing right?
And you know,
in an actual formal scientific setting,
you do an experiment,
you run the data and you do the
analysis,
but is it right or is it not?
Let's see if I can prove it's not.
Even though I really think it is really
good test,
you get a bonus that comes with it,
which is don't know what else to say.
It's super awesome,
which is if you've tried to take your
cherished ideas,
some hypothesis that you've come up with
and you've tried 16 different ways to
show that it's wrong and you keep
failing,
well every one of those things you did
to see whether what you thought was true
was actually false.
Now prepares you when somebody now
challenges you and they say,
oh,
but you haven't thought of this.
Well you have.
You have been through it 16 different
ways and that gives you the ability to
navigate almost anything that's thrown
at you because you have taken on the
role of being your own harshest critic
in order to make sure that what's left
at the end of that process is really
robust.
The other thing that I want to insert
here is that I think a,
I don't want to be put in the position
of defending everything that's been
published in the scientific literature
is true because it looks like science,
a lot of it isn't.
A lot of what's published in the
scientific literature is not valid.
The methodology does not establish what
people claim it does and that's a big
hazard for,
for people like heather and myself
because you have to sort the wheat from
the chaff in order to figure out what to
defend and what to be agnostic about.
Um,
but I do think those of us who more or
less get the story of what let's say
human sexuality is about at a scientific
level and there's still a lot of
mystery,
but there's an awful lot that those of
us who have studied it are in agreement
about and civilization is not yet on the
same page with those of us who have
looked at it scientifically.
One thing we have failed to do,
I think,
is to articulate what you will get in
exchange for signing up for a scientific
worldview.
On this topic,
people do not realize that a scientific
worldview is actually the thing that
empowers you to navigate your own love
life in an intelligent way.
It will let you.
It's a lot more fun than it sounds when
you say it that way.
Yeah.
It's.
Well,
are all of these famous arguments about
unweaving the rainbow or you know,
somebody challenged fineman that,
um,
he,
he was the kind of guy who would take a
part of flour and destroy its beauty in
order to figure out how it worked and
the trip science will destroy beauty.
Right?
And it's not true.
No,
it's not true.
You will get a lot of value.
You will waste less of your time on
people that you shouldn't be interested
in.
If you understand what game they're
playing,
even if they don't understand,
what do you think that arguments coming
from?
The argument that science would destroy
beauty?
Well,
I think there's a way in which the hate
the borrower chemical analogy here,
but there's something called the
activation energy of a chemical
reaction,
which is the energy necessary to get it
to happen and the activation energy for
understanding your own self,
your sexual self,
even as a product of evolution that is
wired in a particular way for particular
objectives that may or not be relevant
to your conscious person's objective,
that that takes a little bit.
It doesn't take forever,
but you know,
if we were teaching a class,
it might take three or four weeks full
time with one set of students before
people who had walked through the door,
not thinking in those terms at all
about,
uh,
their own love life could begin to spot
how this actually maps onto what they
have experienced and what it suggests
they might do differently.
So I think the answer to your question
is it's not cheap to get through the
door.
In the end.
It's an absolute bargain.
What advise you is so valuable compared
to what it costs you to,
to learn it.
But it doesn't come immediately.
It's not like you know an aphorism that
you can adopt and suddenly your life
functions,
so let's start,
look,
but it begins to do as people start to
realize the power of an evolutionary
take on sex and gender or whatever it is
we're talking about is it opens up doors
to inquiry and it makes.
It allows people to make sense of their
lives and then it becomes more beautiful
and more powerful and once people have
seen how you can use these evolutionary
tools and the knowledge that evolution
that evolution has given us,
like male and female are universals like
male and female have existed for over a
hundred million years and everywhere it
shows up,
it looks really similar and yes,
there are exceptions all over the place.
There's amazing ways that you know,
like this crayfish that you have a
sexually reproducing ancestor that's
gotten asexual or you have six full
reversal in some species.
You have Gina's which have a very
strange system going on.
Lots and lots of these exceptions,
but the truth underlying them is always
the same and that's freeing.
So actually that's beautiful.
Can we try it with the crayfish here?
Sure,
so looking at this system,
you've got a creature that is capable of
going asexual and then spreading very
rapidly.
We have lots of examples of creatures
that do that,
right?
Like so.
For example,
Dandelions,
dandelions look like a regular old
flour,
but they're not a dandy lion are what's
called Apa mechanic and an academic Dick
means that they go through my tosas
instead of Meiosis and they produce a
seed that isn't the product of sex and
that seed dispersers as if it was the
product of sex,
and so this does something for
dandelions.
It allows them to take over a landscape
from one individual because it can just
spread and spread and spread without
having to find mates.
It's very effective,
but what we see in systems like heather
mentioned whiptail Lizard,
whiptail lizards,
some populations are asexual and it's.
It's a really cool system.
Actually.
I don't know if Jamie wants to bring up
a picture of a whip tail lizards,
but in the asexual populations,
females can.
I believe they cloned themselves,
right?
It's more or less.
Yeah,
so they.
So the,
the reason we're talking about that is
they're two different ways they could go
about it,
they could make two gametes and fuse
them,
or they can clone themselves.
They're effectively.
But the,
uh,
you look at that system and you say,
well,
how can a population abandoned sex and
be able to tolerate change?
Well,
it has to do one thing,
which is it has to have some place to
borrow genetic variation from.
So we see some very curious behaviors
and these whips,
males,
females,
mount each other.
So basically you have,
you have females who stimulate each
other to produce eggs that are not the
product of sex,
right?
So they retain sexual behavior and then
the student population and whether
they're playing the female role or the
male role in the seed of copulation
depends on their status in the
ambulatory cycle.
But the kicker is,
and you know,
uh,
heather and I were actually teaching
from this and trying to figure out how
the system could possibly be stable
longterm.
And what we predicted actually was that
they had to be borrowing,
um,
genetic variation periodically.
And they,
it turns out that this is true,
they,
how do they borrow genetic variation?
Well,
the populations at the edge of these
clonal populations are sexual and so and
so in the future,
that's what everyone's hoping for.
Some people are hoping for that,
but that's one way.
But then we've got another one.
I mean,
I'm sure your audience isn't thrilled to
be talking about lizards necessarily,
but okay.
Aphids,
aphids are asexual will.
How do they get away with being asexual?
That seems like it would.
Everything we know about sex being so
valuable because of its role in
producing genetic variation.
Um,
what are the aphids doing?
Oh,
the aphids or sexual once a season.
Right?
So they're asexual within the season and
at the end of the season they breed
sexually.
And so the point is,
all of these exceptions are exceptions
that prove the rule that the,
the universality of sex in a complex
animals is I'm broken in certain cases,
but each case that it's broken has a way
of recovering the value of sex.
And then go back to lizards referred one
more lizard example.
Komodo dragons,
which at the biggest monitor lizards,
there's evidence from,
I think it's just as soon as a that
occasionally there's virgin birth,
right?
Occasionally females can produce young
without
sex,
so occasionally individuals will go a
sexual,
which right.
Something that big.
That's crazy.
That is.
It's very rare.
Invertebrates at all and where it does
happen,
it tends to be lizards and it's still
pretty rare as far as we know,
but really for the most part it's.
It would only be in zoos that we would
know for the most part,
but the.
The hypothesis is that this is an
adaptation for than these two.
These are big swimming lizards that are
living on these islands.
They're relatively close together.
They can swim between these islands that
having arrived at an island where
there's none of none else that looks
like you,
it probably makes sense to clone
yourself at that point,
and actually I think they're not clone
all their parthenogenetic,
but it doesn't matter.
They don't.
If,
if it requires two individuals to make
that swim successfully,
in order to populate a new island,
the chances are much lower than if it
just takes one,
and so you can get sex switched on and
off.
Even in Komodo dragons,
that's crazy,
but it isn't.
Think about how many times one of these
animals must have crossed one of these
water barriers and been alone and where
it had an island that it was perfectly
ecologically capable of exploiting.
It had no way of making offspring,
right?
That's a terrible price to pay.
In Darwinian terms,
if the solution is,
well,
let's suspend the requirement of sex for
a generation,
produce some offspring,
and then we can reinstate it,
so really more than likely,
this happens a lot more than we think
and because we assume that sex is the
explanation for vertebrates.
When we see them,
when we encounter them in the wild,
we don't think is this individual the
result of a clonal event.
Whereas this individual,
the result of sex,
we assume sex and it's only when
somebody puts them in a zoo in isolation
that we can be 100 percent certain.
There is no way this animal got
fertilized by another animal and that's
when we start asking the question,
but now that we've started to spot these
things,
we're going to see them more and more
frequently because so many animals over
evolutionary history have been caught in
a situation that was paradise except for
the fact that there wasn't a second one
that is incredibly fascinating though.
They can just switch on and off like
that.
When and if you think about it,
I mean,
monitor lizards are interesting because
they are the,
uh,
the people say they are Mo.
They're the most mammal like
of,
of lizards that live over poor people
who are combined are listed.
So you can look inTo their eyes and it's
a little bit like looking into a dog's
eyes.
They've been paying attention too much
to lizards.
Crazy things I've done.
Well.
Most lizards do.
But these animals that give you a
different impression.
But,
but here's the thing.
Yeah.
But more than geckos,
more than lip tells more than maybe just
bigger.
Yeah,
and they're.
Well,
they're big and long living with more
information out of that big eyeball.
There's a little monitor.
Lizards don't.
People said the same thing about the
little ones,
but
if you think about it,
what triggered this switch?
Profound loneliness,
right?
Profound loneliness would would cause it
so I don't know.
It's impossible to say whether any
lizards including monitors have
something like loneliness.
Although in other cases,
you know when we look at elephants,
we see clear evidence of grief and we
know that elephants didn't get grief
from a shared ancestor with us that had
grief.
They separately evolved grief because
they're complex social structures
required for the same reason that ours
do.
So it's not impossible.
That loneliness might not feel exactly
the same to a monitor lizard,
but if it had a value to detect how
lonely you are and then to trigger a
physiological response that they're than
kickstarted the ability to be
evolutionarily successful that we would
see.
We would see that kind of thing.
So I would love to see somebody try to
figure out whether there was a cognitive
trigger that looked like loneliness in
monitor lizards that actually caused the
switch and if you could then maybe
trigger it.
Wow.
So like some something that you could
actually map and an mri or something on
the brain,
like you look at their little brain and
see loneliness.
Sure.
I mean you hit,
it hits a certain frequency and then
eggs starts forming something.
I mean,
you know,
there would be some cascade,
but yeah,
there'd be some perception that I
haven't seen another one like being a
very long time and then it would cause
some sort of a shift in behavior.
Maybe it would coSt searching behavior
and searching wouldn't let any evidence.
There's no evidence,
you know,
you don't necessarily have to see
another individual to know that they're
around.
But anyway,
there'll be some cascade of things.
And then maybe some,
uh,
a neurotransmitter would trigger the
release of a hormone that would call it.
It would clearly be limited to females
general,
although I don't go ahead because the
egg can,
it has all the cytoplasmic material
unnecessary to make another cell and
sperm doesn't.
Right.
So you know,
sperm,
sperm and egg are just different and
eggs can't move and so they're stuck
where they are.
They have to be found a and m,
but they have all the cytoplasm and
sperm really fast but doesn't have any
of the material necessary to make a
sale.
So a sperm can't mature into a zygote on
fertilized because it doesn't have
mitochondria and replacement,
particularly among all the other stuff
of a cell.
So they're doing different things just
like male and female are different
strategies.
Egg and sperm are different strategies.
So there are certain animals or certain
things that can switch sexes?
Yes,
absolutely.
Which also which organisms can do that
while there's lots of refinish would be
a big cluster of them.
I've heard about ocean fish or their
land creatures that do that.
There's one frog where there's a little
bit of evidence,
but it seems that it may be an artifact
of a,
of a zoo setting effectively,
which might mean that it can happen in
the wild and we just haven't seen it,
but it's well known in reef fish like
there,
there are a lot of species of reef fish,
uh,
that and it,
and it goes both ways.
So this is called a
sequential hermaphroditism were a,
in some species there.
Everyone's born female and then some
transition into males.
And in some it's the other way around.
You transitioned from male to female.
There's some spaces where you can go
both ways and it depends on the sex
ratio around you and sort of what
strategies there aren't enough of.
So male and female are strategies and if
you are the most dominant female in a
landscape and the mail just died,
it makes sense to turn into a male so
that you can now fertilize all those
females.
But they're also.
So that's the sequential,
you know,
we're one individual will transition
between sexes,
but there are also cases like turtles
where there's no chromosomal sex
determination and the sex is effectively
chosen by the environmental conditions,
by temperature in the nest,
and so one individual lives its entire
life within a sex,
but that sex was not dictated when the
egg was laid,
it was dictated by the environment the
egg mature,
done.
Isn't that the case with crocodiles as
well?
Crocodiles,
and in fact,
most,
most every vertebrate that we know,
except for mammals and birds and the
mammals and birds,
it's a different evolution of genetic
sex determination.
So most lizards,
snakes,
frogs,
crocodiles,
turtles,
teleost fish have some kind of
environmental sex determination.
And actually as long as we're going down
this road,
I promise you there's someplace cool to
go with school already.
Okay,
good.
I never know.
I never know how inTerested people are
in the animal science,
but um,
so in human beings and mammals and not
all mammals,
the monitoring teams are exceptional in
this regard.
But the kid doesn't platapus yeah,
there are three species left on earth.
That's a remnant of an early,
early branch on the mammal tree,
but um,
in,
in most mammals like us,
we have chromosomal sex determination
and males are x,
y,
and females are xx in birds.
The situation is exactly reversed as it
is in butterflies.
So what that tells you is that to the
extent that by reversed what brett means
is,
and we just use different letters just
so as not to be confused,
males are so called homo comedic or ww,
whereas in mammals,
females or hamburg,
munich,
xx,
and in birds,
males are comedic.
Ww and females are wc,
which means that female birds can't
clone themselves as the way that,
say a komodo dragon could.
But the reason I raise it is because we
have a sense of male and female vet.
I think it's just wrong that male and
female are actually akin to a niche that
these are roles that the universe
discovers periodically because they make
sense,
right?
So,
um,
it's a convergence on a set of behaviors
that fit well together.
Once you have a small mobile gametes,
you tend to acquire the traits that go
along with maleness.
And this is true,
when an animal switches sex in the
middle of its life,
the behavior switches along with the
gametes.
This is true between birds and mammals.
So the which one has two different sex
chromosomes,
does not predict the behavior,
but which one lays the egg,
does predict the behavior,
and it gets even weirder than that.
So jamie,
do you have that image of the flower,
the image image of those?
Have you ever seen him look at this
flower on the youtube version or what
kind of flowers?
It,
it's actually just a diagram of a
flower.
I just standard flower was that woman
who makes those flower paintings at all
according vagina's a Georgia?
Yes.
That's our joke here.
So this is not her work.
She's a little obsessed.
Talk to her.
No doubt.
Hey lady,
do you paint other stuff?
So here's what I want to show you about
this.
And I must say I love this point even
though I'm,
I'm less jazzed about plants than I am
about animals.
Um,
if you look at the thing,
there is labeled stigma.
The stigma is Connected to the style
which leads to the rules,
so the obvious ones are the.
The eggs essentially,
and the anthers are the place to produce
this pond.
So this flower is a hermaphrodite.
It has both male and female parts,
but here's the really interesting thing.
The female parts are kind of reluctant
about sex with strangers.
The male parts are really enthusiastic
about it,
right?
Really?
Yes.
So those pollen grains will try to
fertilize anything they land on,
but that long style Is basically a test
that the female part of the plant
exposes any pollen grain to the pollen.
Grain has to grow a pollen tube down
that long style in order to get to the
eggs.
In other words,
that flower,
the female parts are koi and the male
parts are a bit randy.
Now this is one plant.
This is one flower that does not agree
with itself about how enthusiastic to be
about sex with strangers.
So you can predict this just on the
numbers too,
right?
It's going to produce,
I don't know what orders of magnitude
more pollen than it has to be
fertilized.
Only got a few chances at picking the
right pond to be fertilized,
but the pollen can be broadcast and go
anywhere and if it's successful and it's
not that successful,
it's still okay.
It's still kind of a win.
So the payoff for putting up with
talking about plants here is if you
realize there's something in the
universe that even when it's building a
plant,
which is really not like an animal,
even when it's building a plant and we
look at and we say,
ah,
these are the boy parts,
and those are the girl parts.
They actually have some analogy to males
and females amongst animals Where we can
spot the behavior easily and that,
that is mind blowing because you correct
me if I'm wrong here,
but the common ancestor between these
plants,
these land plants that have a pollen and
[inaudible] like this and animals that
have eggs and sperm,
the common ancestor is a single celled
photosynthetic ocean creatures,
single cell creature.
It's not like.
So it's not a coMmon,
it's not,
um,
it's not a complex creature.
So what that means is that two totally
different claims that are built around
totally different rules at the point
they get around to spitting out
something that looks like two sexes.
It recover some of the things that we as
human beings are familiar with from
shakespeare,
right.
The point about male and female is so
general that it even covers plants and
then okay,
that's true.
And then we have fungi which break every
single rule.
They don't look anything like this.
They do have stuff that we would regard
as different sexes,
but they can have like 50.
I think they're even hundreds of mating
types in some species of fungi.
So it's not that the universe says this
is the only way to organize a creature,
but it does say this is the way a
creature will be organized if certain
things are true.
Like there's something like in something
sperm like.
So that's very powerful when we're
reaching into Biology and we're saying
male and female are patterns of behavior
that tend to be associated with certain
types of gametes.
When you have two gammy types,
something called nsi gummy,
you will have two sexes and the sexes
will follow rules that we see over and
over and over again.
Repeated plants,
animals.
One of the things that we discussed in
the green room before the show started
was that what we are as some weird
animal that can communicate in very,
very complex ways and one of the things
that we do when we can communicate in
such complex ways is explain all these
things that we've learned about science,
but another thing that we do is we
distort reality to fit what we would
desire it to be rather than what it is.
How much of that is what's going on
today?
A huge amount and unpacking that,
learning not to impose your expectations
on nature is key to understanding it and
it really is a skill you have to learn
and you know that way when nature does
tell you something about what males and
females are like and you know that
you're not talking about something that
you've learned by being human.
You're talking about something you've
learned by looking at other creatures.
Then there's a lot of power and
understanding what those patterns are,
especially when you get to humans
because of all the creatures.
I think this is fair to say,
of all the creatures that I've spent
anytime thinking aBout humans are maybe
sexually the weirdest our ducks.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
of ducks for the most part.
On average on average,
but I'm human beings are partially sex
role reversed.
Okay.
That's sex role reversal is not unheard
of in an animal's that happens,
but our sex role reversal is so weird
and it is not complete.
So there's stuff going on in human
beings that is absolutely novel.
I mean,
in fact,
here's a mindblowing fact that reallY
you could start here and just follow it
back to the implications of this.
There are.
How many species of mammals do you think
there are?
Half a million?
No,
no,
no.
You're way off.
Thirty,
30,
and then a few months there are,
uh,
there are aBout 4,000,
5,000
that we think really.
Well,
I still think it's forecast.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
this is going to mess me up because I
don't know how to work back from $5,000.
I don't know which played has Grown,
but yeah,
we've got about 5,000
species of the racers are pretty
consistent.
Step pretty good.
So half of them are rodents.
A quarter of them are bats.
That one.
I studied bats in graduate school.
That was my thing.
People never expect that.
A quarter of all mammal species for
bats.
That's pretty crazy.
Anyway,
we got that.
Never been to austin for four to 5,000
species of these things.
Human beings are the only one of those
mammal species in which breasts remain
enlarged.
When not lactating.
I find that fact absolutely remarkable.
You have.
You have four to 5,000
species of lactating animals and in
human beings,
breasts have been made persistent when
not lactating.
And in sexual interactions,
they've obviously become a signal and we
know more or less what they already
signal of.
They are a signal of um,
having the resources to produce a baby,
which doesn't.
It doesn't,
uh,
registered with us as important as it.
It should.
It's much more important to our
ancestors.
It was a vital characteristic because
most of the time females were either
pregnant,
they were feeding a baby and therefore
not fertile.
They were starving and therefore not
fertile.
And so a fertile female who is
essentially advertising that she has the
resources to produce a viable offspring
is a,
a rare commodity.
I mean,
I hate to talk in those.
I mean nothing normative by it.
I'm just simply describing it in sort of
as if I was an alien looking down on
people in their evolutionary history,
but the fact that that signal finds
itself,
um,
utilized in the way that it does on the
internet tells us where we are.
We know what I'm saYing.
So one of the other things that is
unique about humans,
at least with regard to our most recent
ancestors,
the other primates,
is that we have concealed isolation.
So you can't tell when a woman is
fertile.
Whereas you can tell when a baboon is
fertile or a monkey or a chimp.
You've got sexual swellings and other
indicators of fertility.
HoW do those lizards find out?
Because if they determine which female
plays the stimulation role in the
regulation cycle,
it's probably going to be chemical.
So some kind of smell pheromone sent
thing vomeronasal some large.
So you see reptiles putting out their
tongue,
um,
what they're doing is they're picking up
large molecules that don't volatilize
and then they are touching an organ that
they have that's connected to their
brains to detect a kind of chemical
signal that weirdly enough,
I don't know how true this story is
going to end up being probably true,
but I have a little trepidation about
it.
There's a,
uh,
an Oregon that detects these large
molecules,
the foamer no nasal Oregon,
and it's like having another sense of
smell that we just don't,
we can't intuitive what it would be like
because we don't have it.
But we actually do have remnants of the
Oregon.
it's just not plugged in.
Yeah.
The story is humans have it,
but it's not.
It's not connected up.
I will not be surprised if it is
something that we're not confident of.
I won't be surprised if it turns out to
be important in some way.
We didn't know the tonsils or the
appendix of turned out to have values
that we should have guessed,
but humans have these persistent,
constant sexual signals in the form of
breasts,
among other things,
and then also have obscured when we are
and are not fertile and so more than any
other primates.
Humans have basically constant sexual
availability,
constant sexual interest,
and yes,
there are ebbs and flows and such,
but,
but female humans more than female.
Chimps are baboons.
Are there any other primates are
interested in sex more reliably across
their ambulatory cycle than,
than any of these other primates?
Yes.
Let's unpack that a little bit.
So in human beings,
um,
ovulation is concealed so that it is not
clear when a female is fertile,
it is concealed from the female herself.
Now that always gets pushed back if you
say that in a room full of students
because they say,
I know,
but the truth is women do not know
reliably.
You can do Things like monitor
temperature and you can get a much
better sense,
but it is novel tools,
right?
That no one had until 50 years ago.
At the most to many women feel it in our
body that maybe,
but some who claimed to be able to,
and there may be some self knowledge
possible there,
so people also claim to be able to pick
lottery tickets.
I can pick up winning ones.
I'm not prepared to say that that never
happens,
right?
But the interesting fact is that this,
when a woman is fertile,
does not have to be obscure to the woman
at all.
Evolution appears to have taken that
piece of information away about boone
would know when it was fertile and it
would alter its behavior.
A female bevin boys when she was
fertile.
Do you think that's because over time
people have discerned.
I mean over the course of evoLution,
people have discerned that having a
child also is partially a burden and so
maybe more intelligent creatures as
humans got more and more intelligent.
They said,
wow,
it seems like a little inconvenient to
have a child or as a baboon would not
think that way and not contemplate the
future.
So there was some sort of evolutionary
advantage for it to be concealed and
humans and for outright displays of
sexuality to be prominent throughout
their entire life.
I suspect the answer is a whole lot more
horrible than that really.
I suspect.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Horrible.
Which is that to the extent that a woman
knows when she is fertile,
she actually may be
vulnerable.
In other words,
to the extent that sexual too coercive
sex.
Yeah.
So vulnerable to rape.
So that if a woman was outright
signaling that she was obviating the,
she would be more likely to be raped by
other humans.
Oh,
I think there's no question about that.
Um,
so
in,
in a sense,
hiding this information from everybody
appears to be an evolutionary solution
to a problem.
I don't think we can name it exactly
because so much is obscure about our
recent ancestors.
You know,
we only have bones,
nothing else fossilizes.
and that doesn't mean that the behavior
doesn't fossilized.
So there's a lot we can't say,
but it is interesting arriving at the
present,
we have modern women and we can say it
is interesting that evolution has robbed
women themselves,
have a piece of information that one
would initially think would be so
valuable
that it would be prominent
to be obscure at all is fascinating.
So the other thing that heather
mentioned,
which I think belongs front and center
in this conversation,
is having sex for Pleasure rather than
reproductive purposes.
So we're not the only ones to do that.
There was dolphins,
others.
There are a few,
but it's rare.
It's very rare.
There are a few other species that
appeared to do this and they don't
appear to do it.
The way humans done at is a dolphin
example.
Is it year round?
Do you know?
I don't remember.
So anyway,
the that sex in human beings has taken
on these other important roles in pair
bonding,
for example,
is very special and the fact that it
continues after menopause.
I mean menopause itself is special
menopause.
The idea that that's not your
reproductive apparatus failing due to
age,
that is your reproductive apparatus.
Deciding to shut down because you've
moved into a new phase.
Basically you've moved into the grandma
phase and the grandma phases essential
in humans where it is not essential in
almost any other creature.
I think elephants occasionally and
orcas,
I believe orc has also have that
pattern,
but um,
but anyway,
all of these things are so different
about humans and they have so much to do
with sex that having a mind numbing
conversation about sexual signals in
modern times is,
it's actually just kind of painful to
listen to it because you want all of
these pieces of information on the table
so that at the point we get to the
discussion about what,
what do we do about modernity that we're
not,
you know,
playing with toys.
We're actually talking about the real
stuff.
This modernity.
I mean the way human beings represent
sexuality or the way sexuality is
represented.
Um,
what's wrong with it?
Like what,
what are the,
what are the key things that stand out
as an evolutionary biologist?
Um,
well let me try an experiment with you.
This,
this is a.
I'm concerned.
This isn't gonna work,
but I hope,
I hope it does.
Even if it doesn't work,
go to work.
Um,
I,
w I would like to try and experiment
with you as a,
a red blooded male.
Okay.
I would like you to conjure the image in
your mind of a woman who is not
beautiful,
but it's hot.
Hmm.
Okay.
Can you do it?
Sure.
Okay.
Can you conjure the image of a woman who
is beautiful but not hot?
Yes.
No Problem.
No problem.
Me either.
Um,
this I think actually is a window into
much that is wrong with what we think
about human sexuality.
I think most people,
if you ask them without doing that
little experiment to conjure a or to
define what,
what it is for somebody to be hot,
you would get answers and people would
tell you that hot was sort of like the
height of beauty,
right?
Which is very frightening if that's true
because hotness wanes with age.
It deteriorates.
Just can't help it.
The discovery,
that beauty actually is a different
parameter tells a whole different story
about what's going on with us.
People with men and with women,
and I think both men and women are
confused by I'm so if it is true,
and I mean I know it is true,
I can look inside my own mind and I can
say that at least for some men it is
true that beauty and hotness are almost
uncorrelated.
There are people who have both traits,
but I,
uh,
I have no trouble seeing that image of a
woman who is hot but not the least bit
beautiful.
And I know lots of women who are
beautiful and not hot.
And I also,
if I take the category of women who are
beautiful but not hot,
um,
there are a lot of older women in it,
right?
I know women in their sixties and
seventies who have Poise have aged
gracefully.
They're gray as can be.
They may be wrinkled,
but if you talk to them,
one does have the sense I'm talking to a
beautiful person,
right?
And I'm not,
I'm not being modeled in here.
If it was just a simple fact that both
beauty and hotness wane with age,
I would say so.
But it is not the case.
So what's going on?
Why do we have these two categories and
why do we assume,
I mean if you look at advertising,
you will get the message that hotness is
where it's at,
right?
Hotness is the thing that's the only
standard possible.
It's the only standard.
And so women are aspiring to it and then
they're fighting it as it wanes.
And all of this,
and I'm here,
here's what I suspect is up because
males are males,
they have,
I want to say they have to reproductive
strategies really.
They have three reproductive strategies
and one of them is a so awful that it's
really just unpleasant even entered into
the discussion,
but new tournament,
right?
Yep.
Yeah.
So the first reproductive strategy that
men have,
the one that would generally have
succeeded and that by the way,
we can talk about monogamy versus
polyamory and all of that at some point.
But,
uh,
I'm not saying anything that is
inherent,
it's not Inherently about monogamy.
The way males have typically reproduced
is they have invested in their offspring
and the mothers of their offspring.
That's the goto mechanism for
reproducing as a human.
Why?
Because human babies are so needy that
one person trying to raise them on their
own is hobbled by just the sheer
difficulty of trying to manage an infant
and a toddler while trying to accomplish
the other things of being a person.
So let me just add here that the idea
that monogamy has been ubiquitous
throughout human history is not
completely accepted,
but that there is good evidence for it
and a lot of fronts and one of the
points against it is that we remain
somewhat sexually dimorphic.
That men are on average,
a bit taller,
a bit more muscular,
much more muscular,
um,
but that we are so much less sexually
dimorphic than even our ancestors beef,
you know,
in more times then when we were,
she didn't read most recent common
assets with chimps that we are moving
towards a more monogamous situation.
So just,
I think you said something that was
unclear at the beginning.
There has been a lot of polygyny where
one male has multiple females in human
history.
Probably the majority of human cultures
have been polygynous.
Yes.
Majority of people on earth today belong
to cultures that are at least nominally
monogamous,
and we should talk about what that shift
is and what it means to us and what's
desirable and all of that.
But the basic point that human babies
are so expensive and difficult to raise
that you need a team to do it.
And you know,
in part this is a chicken and egg
question is not a good term because it's
quite clear which came first.
But um,
the,
this is a situation where the,
when you have a team,
you can also afford to have a baby
that's more needy and there is nothing
good about a needy baby,
but there is something good about what
you can get.
If you can tolerate a needy baby,
you can get a baby that's a lot more
nuanced when it grows up.
So males have traditionally invested in
offspring,
um,
but a male who is investing in their
offspring,
should they happen on an opportunity in
which a female who is fertile and
capable of producing an offspring does
not require commitment from them in
order to have sex.
That's an evolutionary bargain.
A male who can either convince a female
or finds a female who's willing to
produce a baby,
but not expect any support in return.
That such a power.
It's like winning the lottery
evolutionarily.
So it would have almost never happened
in history because women,
because babies are so expensive,
are wired to avoid like the plague.
You don't want to get stuck raising a
baby on your own if you could,
through committing to somebody get a
partner in raising an offspring.
So how does birth control factor into
that?
Well,
we'll get there in a second,
but let's just get the two strategies on
the table.
Males in general have succeeded
reproductively by investing in their
offspring and their offsprings.
Mothers,
when they have the opportunity to
produce offspring with no commitment,
they have a hard time resisting that
opportunity because it's such an
evolutionary when.
But that doesn't mean it would have been
very common in history because females
would avoid it.
So my art can't look away from hot is
about that second strategy,
right?
So hot is this channel that men can
they.
They are wired in such a way that they
actually had been robbed of every useful
term.
They are triggered by the sight of a
woman who is broadcasting hotness.
Right?
And um,
so anyway,
the,
the thing that I think is most important
about this is we now live in a culture
where we have advertisers essentially
creating a kind of insecurity because
insecurity causes people to spend money
they otherwise wouldn't.
That insecurity has women trying to
capture male attention by broadcasting
hotness,
which of course works because men have a
hard time ignoring hotness,
but what I think women often don't
understand is that getting a man's
attention by broadcasting hotness has
him in the frame of mind of this second
reproductive strategy and it is actually
counterproductive to getting his
attention for the first reproductive
strategy because men have historically.
This is by the way,
this is where I'm going to get in huge
trouble with people because this is
going to sound like an accusation.
Really.
I'm just trying to describe what has
been and then we can talk about what we
should do about it,
but I'm a woman who values herself
highly in reproductive terms,
will not leap on,
uh,
a sexual opportunity just because it's
available because what's at stake is so
great.
Historically for women,
this is not true anymore because of
birth control,
but historically it would be true that a
sexual interaction is basically baby
roulette and baby roulette is a
dangerous game to play.
So we get at some of what's true
underneath the stereotype of the madonna
whore dichotomy that neither of those
words is quite right because no one
wants a madonna and elements of virgin
is a life partner,
right?
You want to have a vibrant sexual
relationship with your life partner,
but the,
are you triggering the hotness?
Can I get a baby out of you and never
see it?
I'm a strategy and men,
or are you triggering the,
oh my god,
you're gorgeous and I feel like we could
do this together.
I hate to interrupt you,
but you got to pull this thing close to
them.
Sorry,
just just move that sucker around.
So it's,
so it's comfortable where you're
sitting.
How about that?
It's very different.
It sounds okay in our ears,
but it's very different as the audio.
Sorry.
Perfect.
Now.
Good.
So,
um,
so,
so anyway,
the,
the madonna whore complex,
which is this famous thing isn't the
paradox that we are led to believe men
are interested in,
you know,
as heather points out,
madonna and whore or the wrong terms,
they're very charged,
but men are interested in both of these
reproductive strategies but they are not
interested.
They're not paradoxically searching for
them in the same individual will.
Isn't there an issue also that today
human beings,
males in particular are not looking at
women purely in terms of someone to
reproduce with.
They're looking in terms of what is
sexually pleasurable,
what did they find attractive and when
they see a person,
it is almost,
it's very rare that they look at a woman
and say,
this is a who I would
like to breed with.
They'd say,
I would like to practice reading with
her,
but,
but here's where our language gets in
the way,
right?
Like we were telling ourselves stories
based on,
I mean got birth control changed
everything actually and really so new.
Exactly right.
It's so new.
I mean there's,
there are not very reliable forms of
birth control and lots of cultures
around the world,
but actually fully reliable birth
control is decades old,
so we shouldn't expect the stories we
tell ourselves about what we're looking
for to be a match for what we're
actually looking for yet because we
just.
We haven't had time to update our
software even ride,
so the software is still wired the same
way to look at a woman who you believe
would be a good carrier of babies,
someone who would be very maternal,
someone who's attractive,
they have good features.
This would be someone who you'd want to
breed with.
Whereas the second option would be
someone who you could sneak it in on.
I would say with regard to the first
strategy,
it's,
it's more than that.
More so that the first strategy as you
just described,
it sounds very traditional female role.
Right?
And mostly,
especially when populations are moving
across frontiers and actually like
expanding the scope of where humans
were,
what you needed in a partner,
both male and female with someone with
whom you could share all of life's
challenges,
right?
It wasn't just about taking care of
baby,
uh,
because you know,
dad was a also doing parental care,
but uh,
mothers and fathers were in it together
and it was their division of labor of
course.
And was the specialization of course,
that that specialization always look the
same?
No,
it didn't.
In fact cross culturally,
this is fascinating,
like some tasks and up highly gendered
across cultures.
But which gender does it,
is different,
like weaving turns out to be a pretty
highly gendered task and different
cultures.
But sometimes it's only women who do it
and sometimes it's only men.
And you know,
there are some things that really only
men do in most cultures.
And this is,
this is a great review,
an anthropology paper from the early
seventies.
So this is mostly preindustrial cultures
they're looking at.
But the jobs that across cultures where
it happens,
only men do include the hunting of large
marine mammals,
an iron smelting.
Those two things,
those two.
Then there's a few others,
but those are the top,
the largest marine mammals.
But at the same time it's whale hunting
and smelting of ors.
Wow.
Yeah,
definitely don't do that.
It doesn't burn a hole in your boat.
You keep quenching the thing by
accident.
And um,
yeah.
So I think you know,
the answer to the question you asked is
that the whole system has been hijacked
by the novelty of our current
circumstances.
And what I was trying to get at before
is that the size of the wind of an
ancestral male who reproduced with a
that didn't require investment from
them.
The size of that,
when is so great that it causes men to
default to thinking about that when it
appears to be available.
And so in a world where there's birth
control and therefore the stakes for
women for having sex had been greatly
reduced and therefore more women are
interested in having sex without
commitment.
The problem is men don't really know
what they're looking for because there
is this,
uh,
this level of triggering that they
cannot overcome.
And so the other point I want to make on
this front is yes,
men are interested in sexual pleasure as
our women men and women are overlapping
but distinct in what that means.
But I think if we were to say,
hey,
sexual pleasure is awesome and you
should live your life so as to maybe not
maximize it,
but come close to maximizing it,
that sexual pleasure,
so desirable that you should live your
life in a way that you get as much of
that thing as you can.
That would not necessarily say that the
way to do it was to go around banging
strangers,
right?
Because this is a multifaceted,
a phenomenon and there is one thing that
gets left out of this discussion almost
every time I hear people talk about it,
which is that the sex that one has,
when the stakes are really high,
right?
When you're really into somebody that's,
that's a very pleasurable kind of sex
that is not reproduced by low stakes
situation.
And so we're comparing things and it
sounds like,
well,
sexual pleasure is what you're after
then more sex is certainly the way to
get there.
But you know,
um,
it tends to look like the argument tends
to be more sex with more people,
more varied sex partners is the obvious
way to optimize sexual pleasure.
And actually that assumption hasn't been
investigated and wasn't a difficult to
accomplish.
What is that,
why it's not,
it hasn't really been investigated.
I mean how many people are having sex
with multiple partners and take notes
and being studied.
Well I don't know.
I mean college students,
you know,
right.
But tell you anything for 50 bucks.
So there are lots of these studies that
do involve asking a lot of college
students,
which is not,
you know,
it's not a very broad sample but,
but again,
this is a fairly new phenomenon of the
last five,
six decades where you could do it and
not worry about reproducing.
Well,
so the question really is if we step
back from our own lives and we say,
what,
what would the rules be if I wanted to
maximize this set of things,
if I wanted to get these values out of
my life,
how would I alter my behavior?
Um,
I don't think you would come up with,
hey,
sex with strangers is the answer to all
of this.
In fact,
I think sex with strangers is,
um,
it's pretty low grade in terms of what
it delivers.
So,
so there are some cultures that
encourage a lot of early fooling around
between,
between individuals and it's considered
low stakes and it stops at some point.
And that's one thing that what's going
on in modern american culture is there's
no end point.
It's just considered a good,
uh,
that more sex with more strangers is
inherently going to result in more
pleasure.
And therefore,
if we're actually interested in sexual
pleasure,
that's what we should be doing.
And if you,
if you look at cultures that have taken
sexual pleasure seriously,
if you look at like a tantric sex,
right?
It isn't about sex with strangers,
it's about cultivating a sexual
relationship that increases sexual
pleasure to an extreme height that you
won't reach if you aren't careful in
architecting it.
so in other words,
it's about delayed gratification.
I mean,
really that's the missing a idea here is
that delayed gratification is actually a
strong contributor to sexual pleasure.
Isn't this sex with strangers thing
attractive because it's difficult to
accomplish?
Is that part of it?
well,
I said it's not accomplished for men,
but not very difficult to accomplish for
women rights.
It does not that attractive to women,
not nearly as attractive to women as it
is to men for the simple reason that it
should be attractive to us in the city.
Very much so.
Yeah.
And it's because it's imagined that
symmetry is equality.
Okay.
Right.
And that's.
And that's,
I mean,
I think that's
maybe one of the main things we're
pushing back against here is that we are
not making the claim that one sex is
better than the other,
but the idea that we are identical is
absurd on its face.
Well,
in our culTure today,
one of the things that is a big standout
as being very novel is social media.
This is a completely new thing and this
social media also being used to attract
sex partners is a very new thing.
Man.
I had a whole bit in my last act,
uh,
my,
my last netflix special about some girl
who lives in Florida who has not,
she probably have 9 billion people on
our instagram now.
She had 9 million followers and all she
does is take pictures of her ass.
And I was saying science needs to study
her [inaudible].
This is a new type of human being.
We don't know anything about her.
What she,
she has nothing to do with what she
says.
It has nothing to do with what she's
accomplished in life.
It literally is about people focusing on
her ass so fast.
Why is she doing it?
There's a tension,
but she's getting attention.
I'm sure there's an economic benefit to
it too,
but that came later.
The attention came first.
She didn't embark on this journey like
going,
I know what I'll do.
I'm going to figure out how to make
money off my ass.
She decided she comes of age and
discovers that that's asset when
you want it to be or not,
but now I'm being a little bit,
how am I going to play it?
But some number of people play it.
Well,
um,
but.
But again,
I.
So there is what I would call it two way
failure of empathy.
So you'll give me a little,
a little leash here.
We empathize with another individual by
using our own minds and whatever it is
that we have as the content of our
minds.
And then we run the data of somebody
else's situation through our minds and
we say,
how would I feel in that situation?
And in general,
this works really well if you share
circuitry with somebody and it works not
so well where your circuitry is
different.
So there are lots of places where males
and females who grew up,
heather and I both grew up in la.
There's a certain amount of stuff that
we can intuit about,
what the other would think about
something just based on the fact that we
grew up in the same period in the same
place,
um,
but males and females there,
there's a place where we top out and we
can't understand what the other is,
is experiencing because it is very
unlike what we would experience.
So for example,
if,
uh,
if you were walking down the street,
let's say before you were a well known
guy,
okay,
you're an anonymous guy walking down the
street and imagine that there's a group
of women talking somewhere and uh,
you walk by and they're like,
look at that.
That's one fine hunky man.
How do you feel?
A.
Yeah,
whoo.
You feel pretty good,
but I don't feel threatened.
Does certainly don't feel the difference
between a man experiencing that with
women is I'm not going to get gang
raped.
Yeah.
But do you feel good?
Yeah,
sure.
Of course you would.
He that implemented.
right?
But it's very different with the
opposite sex because there's no threat.
It's very different for the,
with the opposite sex.
Not only because it lets neutralize the
threat part of it,
which is,
I mean it's,
it's huge for sure,
but there's other stuff going on,
but here's the part that I think men
don't intuit until somebody points it
out to them because men have two
different reproductive strategies and
one of them is about longterm investment
and the other one is about have sex with
them,
impregnate them,
and never see them again when a man
whistles at a woman.
Right.
And he compliments essentially how hot
she looks.
He is essentially offering to stick her
with a child that will then be her
responsibility for the better part of
two decades.
That's not a very nice compliment.
Right.
Well that's a weird way of looking at
it.
I agree with you,
but I see exactly where you're going
with that.
But man,
I never thought about that way before
and I don't think most people have
either.
Well that was my point though.
It's right in front of us.
The other thing to that,
so you've just identified,
you know,
a single guy kept calling maybe,
right,
but a woman walking
past a construction site and getting
five,
six,
seven guys whistling.
Who are those girls for?
Not necessarily for her.
It's communication between the men
they're signaling than not getting to
each other.
Hey,
did you see that?
I saw that.
I'm into that and I mean that's,
it's a,
yes,
it's a total objectification and it
renders the woman involved.
He was receiving this thing as almost a
nonentity,
but it feels totally personal and yet
it's not necessarily about the woman.
And so you know,
all the discussion of oh my god,
these calls or are awful and it's just,
it's a pain in the ass to walk down the
street and have to deal with it for a
young woman.
It's true.
But it's also ignoring the fact of it
being communication between men and,
you know,
should they stop probably,
but um,
but it's not just about male female
communication.
It's male male competition as well.
That type of communication though only
occurs if you've been raised poorly.
You don't have any sisters or you don't
have any daughters and if you,
if you have all those things years,
some kind of a monster,
like if you have a mother that you love
and a sister that you love and if you
have daughters and you still can't call
it some woman walking down the street,
there's something really wrong with you.
But.
So,
um,
when I was day,
oh,
I think it's,
it's very,
very wrong,
but it doesn't work.
It is also so calm.
Yeah,
I don't.
I mean it must,
it must work.
A case works to let the other guys know
you're not gay.
Right.
So that's,
that's part of it doesn't even do that.
No,
actually let's,
I mean this is interesting because I
think this is something actually heather
probably won't intuit either,
but I'm wondering if you'll spot it.
When I,
when I mentioned it,
which is there is a part of being a male
that.
Because I mean,
the thing is most males in history are
losers who didn't reproduce,
right?
Reproduction was not that easy to
accomplish in human history.
It was way easier to starve or die on a
battlefield or a lot of other things.
Um,
so the,
um,
there is a way in which there a part of
the male psyche that plays very remote
possibilities.
Right?
And you know,
it's weird if you're talking about being
in a city and construction workers
sitting on a girder,
whistling at somebody walking by.
If we calculate the chances that any one
of them ended up actually in a
conversation with her,
the chances are pretty low.
But if you imagine that those guys are
actually acting from a mind that evolved
in much smaller circumstances.
A small town where everybody knew
everybody.
And so whatever it is in their mind that
causes them to have these interactions
would have been much more likely.
There would be later interactions with
the same person.
And so I think that a male that is not
thinking carefully about what they are
doing ends up,
you know,
flirting with and basically building a
rapport that is about some future
potential that's almost certain never to
be realized.
But it makes sense to cultivate because,
you know,
if you cultivate a thousand tiny little
potentials and almost all of them go
bust,
but occasionally one works out.
That's a win.
So the point is the cost is small.
Um,
and you know,
you never know.
The woman who gets cat called might,
um,
I can't even imagine the circumstance,
but it's that whole,
you never know.
It's like,
just dig a hole in the middle of the
street.
You might find gold.
I mean,
it seems like a hail mary,
but yeah,
sometimes hail mary's work happen some
time in history,
but if you had to look at the numbers
would probably be pretty staggering.
Okay.
So as long as we're in this territory,
yes it must have happened in history,
but so many things that were very remote
contingencies in history have apparently
produce offspring like,
um,
you know,
the,
uh,
apparent tendency of people being hung
to orgasm.
Right?
What is that?
That is likely to be the body taken one
last shot.
There's no point.
There's no way a new one on me.
You're talking about creation.
So we were talking about.
Well actually I wasn't talking about
that,
but it's a better example.
It shows you that there's some part
hung.
What do you mean then?
I mean the actual execution think
grammatically.
I mean being hanged,
being hanged.
Yeah.
I'm so confused.
So that'd be a little more orgasms when
they die.
I'm working from anecdote here.
I have read that I,
but I don't know of any checking the
underwear people just got hung.
But my point would be what has to be
true in order for such a pattern to
evolve?
So let's take auto erotic asphyxiation
strategy.
I mean,
is what you're arguing basically this is
um,
you know,
dandelions who go to seed as after you
pick them and spread their seats,
right?
Like is that going to work?
Last ditch effort to the production
channel are predict hail marys.
And so the point is,
I think this is probably not obvious
unless you're used to thinking
evolutionarily,
but in order for a pattern to occur
where some entity releases sexual
propagules on death,
in order for that to evolve,
it has to have worked enough times for
that pattern to have accumulated.
And so if autoerotic fixation is the
result of people tapping into that thing
and you know,
traversing a landscape near death in
order to increase sexual pleasure,
what that suggests is that that
landscape near death has actually had a
certain amount of reproduction happened
in it that has resulted in this
circuitry being present.
Can you imagine a scenario?
And can you imagine a scenario where
that trait would be passed down to the
offspring?
Uh,
I can imagine that.
I mean,
let's just do it the other way.
Um,
people have had a lot of sex over
evolutionary history.
A lot of bad things have happened to
people over evolutionary history.
Every so often those two things
intersect,
right?
In other words,
every so often the catastrophe,
the enemy spills over the wall,
whatever it is.
And so I,
I don't know,
um,
I,
I don't know what the pattern would be.
It may simply be that jeopardy is the
key factor and actually jeopardy would
be expected to happen an awful lot.
So for example,
to the extent that had,
in fact we see a lot of this stuff in
primates where there's a question about
how public,
um,
the sexual interaction between two
individuals amongst chimps is,
for example.
So when two chimps are having sex,
if the mailchimp is not the dominant
male,
he has everything to lose in being
discovered.
So malicious,
right?
They hide.
And so then the question is,
is the female advertising that they are
having sex by making noises that make it
visible,
in which case that creates jeopardy.
So there's a whole landscape of stuff
that has happened in evolutionary
history both with humans,
with pre humans,
with apes.
You know,
they're not anymore.
I've heard that argued as well about
women with very loud moaning of pleasure
that they're really trying to
attract other males.
Uh,
I think that that waS in sex at dawn.
Well,
I was running.
I would be super cautious about sex at
dawn as a book.
That particular finding,
I think is probably right.
Why would you be cautious about sex at
dawn as a book?
Because the book is,
I believe,
quite cherry picked in order to produce
a particular,
what I regard as a false sophistication
about human sexual behavior.
It makes us out to be wantonly
promiscuous across time in a way that
doesn't seem to actually fit with a more
careful reading of what we are.
How dare you,
chris ryan,
how dare you?
Well,
hello.
No,
I don't know.
I don't know who's right.
Let's put it this way.
That book is a pretty good strategy for
getting people to go to bed with you and
feel sophisticated about.
Ooh hm.
We'll leave that there.
Um,
so the chimps hiding in the bushes,
the,
a beta chimps as it were,
the males would have to hide their
sexuality from the alphas because the
bigger,
stronger males would probably take the
meat from them and then their likelihood
of reproducing whoops.
Would be greaTly diminished.
Oh yeah.
It would be punished for.
They're going to get cuffed to.
Yeah.
It's going to get cuffed or,
or more cuffed.
That's an interesting.
What does cuffed.
Yeah.
That's a funny way of describing it.
Coughed.
Well,
there we are.
Yeah,
we get stuck there.
sorry,
my apologies.
I should know what that means is that
I've heard it before,
but it's now,
um,
what out of all this can we unpack,
about the way we're interpreting what's
acceptable and not acceptable about male
and female interaction in 2018?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean we're,
it seems to be getting redefined,
right?
Yeah.
And it's a hot mess.
What's wrong with it as like as a
biologist is a person who understands
humans.
Yeah.
Um,
let's,
let's go to me to write the me too.
Movement looks,
looks like an honorable thing at first
because most men are not nasty human
beings and don't behave towards women in
a way that most women have been behaved
towards by men.
Almost every woman who at all fits
there,
the norms for their culture has been
harassed in some way.
Um,
when they were young woman.
That is just,
that is true.
Most men don't do that.
That's also true.
So imagining that most men are behaving
in some kind of a toxic way.
And I just,
I don't like that word,
but I'm imagining that because most
women have experienced harassment,
most men are therefore harassing is in
error of logic,
of statistics of humanity.
So we go from this place of,
wow,
were there some monsters out there?
Wow,
was it a good moment to reveal some of
the monstrosity that was happening?
And are there some bright lines like I'm
prepared to draw a couple of bright
lines.
Everyone deserves not to be touched if
they don't want to be touched and
everyone deserves to exist in a
situation where there are no quid pro
quos a for instance,
of their employment.
If you want to stay employed or if you
wanted to be an advanced in your
employment,
then you need going to need to do this
sexual thing with me.
Quid pro quos don't don't be touched
when you don't want to be touched.
Those things seem honorable and true and
for god's sake,
can't we all agree to those?
But then it went too far and women are
arguing some.
Some women are arguing that it doesn't
matter if innocent men go down and
because many women have experienced
this,
it must be all men.
I mean,
we were actually hearing from people
that any boy that you are raising is
potentially a rapist.
No,
sorry.
Most men I know couldn't right?
Actually,
it's just it's not
what men are so me two went off the
rails and it had an opportunity to
actually really wake a lot of good men
up to how ubiquitous the experience of
walking around on the streets and I'm
being catcalled and being harassed and
so on as being groped and sometimes
worse than that is for a woman and it
took it to this,
this absurd point where now most I think
increasingly reasonable people are
looking at it,
going,
well then if you're claiming that what
else that you're saying isn't true,
and that puts the.
That puts the early stages of the
movement at risk.
Now when you see the monsters and they
are real,
the male monsters,
monsters are real and you.
You see that now when they're getting
exposed,
like harvey weinstein is a perth easiest
one.
He's the classic example,
right?
When a guy or bill cosby,
when these monsters get exposed,
first of all,
it's a good thing,
but second of all,
don't you think that the reason why they
got away with it in the first place was
because they were able to victimize
these people and secret and that they,
they either had enablers or in cosby's
case,
everyone was unconscious.
I mean there's,
there's some great good to exposing
these things,
but in doing so,
the overzealous approach of accusing all
men of being potential rapists is an
adjust.
Just an overreaction and the balance
itself out.
do you or do you think that it's more
complicated than that?
It's gonna.
It's gonna backfire because the problem
looks like a power grab,
but won't the backfiring balance itself
out?
I mean people,
reasonable people like you or myself or
we're always going to recognize the
difference that there are monsters.
Yes.
Right,
and we're not going to deny monsters
because someone goes too far and they
accused garrison keillor of being a
monster.
When we know that that's not true.
It doesn't make sense.
The story doesn't make sense,
so because most people who I've talked
to about the garrison keillor story,
which he was consoling a woman and he
touched her back and then she pulled
back and he apologized and I didn't mean
to do that,
and then he sent her an email
apologizing and she said,
no big deal,
don't worry about it.
They were good for awhile and then years
later,
right when all this me too thing,
she's just decides I remember something
that was wrong and let's let's take this
guy down,
which didn't make any sense that first
of all,
well let's leave it alone.
Didn't make any sense,
but where's garrison keillor now?
Whereas like he hasn't been resurrected,
it hasn't been resurrected.
They took his shows off the air.
it doesn't have to decide whether or not
you like him as an artist or creator
just like they actually destroyed.
Not just him,
but his legacy for a hug,
for something that at the time both
parties agreed was no big deal.
I just don't understand it.
It's completely unacceptable and it's
the death of justice.
Well,
was that just getting caught up in the
hysteria of just like trying to find
todd.
There's one put that fire out
immediately.
So we have a couple of problems and one
of the problems is that the folks who
are advancing this movement and the
other parallel,
I wish they hadn't taken the term social
justice because we need a replacement
term for that that is not overzealous,
but those movements have engaged in a
kind of naive conclusion.
Making that makes them inevitably
hijack.
They get inevitably hijacked by bad
actors.
So if you,
you are essentially looking at a
situation,
if you say,
we must believe all victims,
that's like putting out a neon sign for
bad actors that wished to utilize this
structure.
Right?
So and there will be bad actors.
Yes.
Every population,
male as a population,
female population,
monstrous males who have been behaving
predatorily,
they will be women who will take
advantage of this and accused people
without reason.
I mean we,
I don't know whether the numbers are
robust or not,
but I've heard numbers that somewhere
between one percent to four percent of
the population are sociopathic.
If you set up a system in which we are
obligated to believe every victim,
then those people will come out of the
woodwork and they will use this to level
their enemies and so at the very least,
what that tells you is rule number one,
you cannot make the rule.
You must believe all victims or you will
have lots of people piling into the
category of victim that don't deserve to
be there and who is hurt most by that
not only the people who are going to be
sabotaged by bad actors,
but the people who have suffered the
worst cases of rape.
They are effectively having the terrible
things that have happened to them
diluted by stories that are either
fictional or minor that are being lumped
in.
So it's further victimization of them.
It is a transfer of wellbeing from the
people who have been most harmed to
people who have been less harmed or are
cynically using these structures.
So if the idea of a me too of the
reckoning that has finally come for
these really terrible guys who were
getting away with all of this awful
stuff.
If that is close to your heart than what
you should want is a set of rules that
is careful enough and robust enough that
we can keep holding those kinds of
people to account what will happen if we
don't do that,
and I promise you this from a game
theoretic perspective,
if we decide you must believe all
victims and all transgressions are
equally bad,
we're going to turn the thing to 11 for
everything from happen.
I agree with you,
but how did that happen?
If you're,
if you're cynical,
it's the type of nuance in part.
Yeah,
it is.
It is a death of nuance because if
you're Wielding this thing as a weapon,
right?
If you.
What you want to do is turn the tables
on all men.
If you want to take power and say you
listen,
well,
this is a frightening weapon.
So in order to make that weapon
maximally dangerous you,
you equate your cat call.
Yeah.
You,
you say it's all one.
There's nothing a woman could ever do
that would increase her likelihood of
facing any of this.
And you know,
we should cover that in a second because
that's one of the,
that's another one of these booby traps
where you can very easily say the wrong
thing and suddenly you're on the
defensive even though what you said is
very rational,
but also it denies the reality of what
male,
female relationships look like when
they're at all healthy.
There'S goIng to be risk.
There is risk as you get to know people.
And I don't,
you know,
we're just meeting say instead of having
met in high school so many years ago,
I don't know if I like you yet,
you don't know if you liked me yet.
We're going to take some chances and
maybe you're going to say something
wrong and I'm not going to be thrilled
with it.
Are you at fault?
Do I?
Do I blame you?
Do I cry?
Harassment?
Because you said something that didn't
quite fall right on my ears or did it
sound right and I kind of like you
anyway.
And so I go like,
it's fine.
You know,
we're good.
Well,
it really depends on,
you know,
how,
how I receive that depends a lot on how
I feel about you.
Otherwise you could say exactly the same
words and you know,
you could say it and someone else could
say it and from that guy I might feel
like I kind of wished you hadn't said
that,
but that has to mean that that isn't a
deep problem that he said it because
we're engaged with something we're
trying to discover.
Do we like each other,
are we into each other like what's going
on here?
So the process of discovery is going to
involve mistake and risk and,
and even some sort of game plan,
you know,
you're involved in the social game in
which you're trying to figure out who
each other are and after the fact saying
that guy is kinda gross.
So the thing that he said was harris
meant.
Sorry.
No,
not,
not acceptable.
It's changing the rules of the game
based on whether or not you liked a
particular individual and that's not a
legit move.
So we,
we got to be super careful here.
One thing that is true is we are facing
a landscape in which
we are,
I think effectively rewriting the rules
of male female interaction in order to
make sex with strangers perfectly safe.
Now,
sex with strangers can't be perfectly
safe in a world in which you're dealing
with.
Let's say it's one percent sociopath's
you can't make a world in which it's
safe to take a sociopath home and have
sex with them,
right?
That,
that's not going to happen,
but in order to try to make it safe,
we're going to turn up all of these
protections.
So for example,
um,
we've got the issue of affirmative
consent.
Now,
affirmative consent is a great fail safe
in a circumstance where you are dealing
with a stranger.
It seems like it would be absolutely
essential because the danger of a
miscommunication is so great that you
have to be perfectly explicit and there
can be.
There's no room for,
uh,
any coyness or subtlety about it.
In other words,
it has to effectively be transactional,
but no courtship that's going to make it
into the history books or literature is
going to involve affirmative consent at
every stage.
You into it.
Yes.
How about now?
Yeah.
Did you guys remember that video that
they released?
There was a video that,
boy,
I don't remember who did it,
but as essentially showing how consent
can be sexy and so it shows this
millennial couple making out and like
every few seconds the guy has to ask the
girl if it's okay if he kisses her,
if it's,
is it okay if I touch you here?
Is it okay if I take your shirt off?
And she says not yet,
and then they keep going and going and
going,
and then the girls asking that guy,
which is hilarious.
Is it okay if I do this?
Like what?
Because this is imagined.
Exactly,
exactly.
It's not symmetric phosphorus.
Right.
Well,
that was also an issue with.
They've sort of abandoned this,
but a few years ago there was this thing
where if you had sex with someone and
alcohol was involved,
you raped them because they could not
consent,
but I'm like,
well,
that means I've been raped a lot of
times because that's ridiculous like it
did,
but it never worked that way.
It does.
If you want symmetry,
you would have to say that if the man
has consumed alcohol and the woman
hasn't,
then the woman is raping the man.
I don't want to freak you out,
but I'm.
Heather and I have been assuming each
other's consent for 30 years.
I mean,
we have inferred it from cues that were
not verbal.
You guys didn't discuss.
What about reading,
writing things down?
Do you have a chalkboard or.
No,
I mean,
and the thing is the only thing that
keeps us safe from being arrested for
this.
We,
we've both done it right now.
It's like,
right,
you're both criminals.
This,
these changing,
these shifting of the rules.
It seems like it's almost like you were
talking about game theory.
It does.
It really does seem like a type of game.
It is life,
but it is a thing where people are
looking to call people out.
You're looking to score,
electing to score a.
You're,
you're finding someone who's done
something inappropriate or finding
someone that has done something that
used to be appropriate but is no longer
and we're looking to establish this new
parameter and this new way of existing
and that there's this.
It takes on this competition element
which I'm very familiar with.
I understand competition so I.
When I see it clearly and I see like
team behavior,
I'm like,
well,
I see what's going on here.
This is not rational thinking.
This is someone who's trying to score
points.
You're trying to get one on the board.
Yes.
It's absolutely competitive and it's
mostly competitive at the moment.
It looks like said if within women and
it's going to destroy.
It's actively making male female
relationships.
Impossible to navigate,
but I understand it for as a man,
I get the motivation.
I think that women overwhelmingly have
been victimized as opposed to like men
being victimized by women in that
regard.
In terms of being sexually harassed.
It's not even close.
I mean,
is it,
is one of the most unbalanced things in
our culture ever completely right?
But it's posted in our culture,
right?
This is what we're talking,
What do we want out of this now that
we've now that it's.
But do you want a hundred percent
safety?
Do you want to maximize safety at the
cost of what?
We have to kill sociopath.
So I want to do that.
The point is,
if you want,
if you want absolute safety,
I mean,
we're,
we're getting to the point where this is
just robbing.
Okay?
If the point of this is to make sex safe
because it's pleasurable,
this is going to rob all of the pleasure
from sex.
I mean,
it's,
it's getting to the point where you'd be
crazy to have sex without witnesses.
You know what I'm saying?
Um,
but,
but anyway,
the point is now that the stuff is on
the table right now,
that we know that there are monsters,
we know that there are economic forces
that actually protect these monsters,
which frankly is a big part of this
story,
right?
Is that the economic structure of
something like hollywood causes this to
continue with it being effectively an
open secret that these people are
abusing women and then silencing them
and contractually obligating them not to
do anything about it,
that that cancer on the social system is
now open for discussion and we,
all of us decent folk know that we have
to get rid of it.
If you get rid of it though on false
pretenses,
I promise you the very same game theory
that caused it to happen in the first
place will cause it to reemerge.
The only reason it will be harder to
address the next time.
Don't you think that this,
the overreaction though has pretty much
calmed down post garrison keillor and al
franken and with al frankin,
obviously there's some pretty obvious
political ramifications to it.
Um,
I don't think.
I don't knoW what state it's in.
I haven't seen the nuanced conversation
breakout.
I haven't seen the description of what
the admin.
So back up the second scene is a
doubling down on.
There are no differences between men and
women.
It's all a social construct who's
doubling down.
But where is this happening and the
universities where the universities and
it's spreading.
I mean,
this is,
this is what the replies to the google
memo we're about.
I mean,
this is,
but isn't google in a sense an extension
of the universities in that regard?
It is,
and it's everywhere.
But it's also a defacto governance
structure,
right?
So it's very frightening.
And you know,
what happens.
I was thinking this morning about a how
a jury of your peers.
That phrase is now increasingly erie.
Which peers are they peers that believed
some false,
uh,
some false story about what human beings
are or are these people who are going to
be able to hear a story that has some
nuance in some gray area in it and take
it in.
And the fact is people,
if you look at what advertisers are
using to access people,
if you look at the narratives that exist
in movies,
people are capable of understanding the
subtlety of human interactions,
but they are either pretending or
convincing themselves in the public
space that things are way simpler than
they actually are.
And what I don't want to see and what I
mean,
again,
I don't have a dog in this fight.
I'm happily married.
I'm not looking for anything else,
but uh,
I do want to see this solved in tiMe foR
our chIldren to face a landscape that
makes sense.
And I would like are many students who
have talked to us about the,
the confusion of trying to navigate a
romance in the current circumstance.
I would like them to what's going on.
Jamie came out yesterday,
said you guys are talking about it.
I don't know how it affects what you're
talking about currently,
but how an outright bought network took
down.
Al franken was on newsweek.
They found it started actually in Japan
and they traced the whole thing of like
the day before Roger Stone tweeted
something about al franken even starting
to be taken down.
And they traced the whole interaction of
bots on twitter doing,
doing this all for a couple of weeks.
Oh,
it does actual women that said he
grabbed there,
but maybe that's this.
They asked him for.
They asked him for comment and he didn't
respond yet because this was just within
the last 24 hours.
I don't know.
I don't know what we should do with the
franken story because the franken story,
it's not empty the way the garrison
keillor story appears to be totally
empty.
On the other hand,
and I mean I think this is probably why
jamie put it up.
We have to think carefully when you're
talking about a senator being brought
down on the basis of these claims that
are tied up in a movement which does not
appear nuanced about the degree of harm
done and things like that.
There is something at stake.
Just you know when there is an
assassination,
you have to ask yourself who benefits
from the absence of this person?
Right.
That the political aSsassination is not
a normal murder.
It is a political act.
It shifts the balance of something.
This is not an assassination,
but it functions like one.
It takes a political actor who stood for
certain things and against other things
and represented certain constituencies
and for others it takes them off the
map.
And so when that happens,
it's really,
it's actually an extension of what we
were talking about,
the bad actor problem before a bad actor
can be a sociopath that wants to advance
their own cause or take out a,
an enemy or something like that.
it can also be a,
um,
a political apparatus or a corporate
entity that wishes to shift the balance
and the political body like theu ,
s senate.
So we have to be mindful.
It is yet another reason that we can't
build naive really.
But yeah,
this is a very good point because we
don't know the motivation of the people
who came out and we don't know if it's
accurate.
He says it's not accurate.
We don't know.
We have no idea.
And what's the price point for a botnet
that can cause the internet to turn on
you?
Maybe it doesn't matter,
but the entry point to that story was he
took a picture,
a comedic picture.
Pretend someone's breasts pretending.
Yeah.
Was it in good taste now,
was it?
No,
no,
but there was a little more to that.
She actually said that he kissed her
like they were doing some sort of a
sketch together and he insisted on
kissing and then he wants to be wanting
to practice the kiss.
She found inappropriate.
Yeah.
That's why I,
you know,
I,
I don't,
I don't love the franken story as an
example here because it's murky.
Yes,
I agree.
Garrison keillor,
very,
very careful to make sure not to accept
you're damned if you do and damned if
you don't like garrison keillor is the
only one that seems completely clean,
but I can basically guarantee you
statistically that there are good men
who are being taken down.
Well.
So the last time I was on,
we talked about matt taibbi and yes,
I don't know one way or the other.
I don't know matt taibbi,
but that story also looked to me like
one in which the portrayal was
manufactured and he has now just won a
settlement from the nation.
The basis of this.
So anyway,
that one appears to have gone in.
What I imagine is the right direction.
Um,
so that,
that's positive,
but I want to return to an earlier
point.
We are talking about what the rules of
interaction should.
It is good that we are talking about it
and it's good that we're finally
addressing the issue of monsters.
Why this didn't get a set loose by bill
cosby?
I don't know because that one appeared
crystal clear to that one.
Built that one.
It started off.
Well,
you know,
I can say as a person who worked as an
actor for a while,
I heard about that story in the
nineties,
but it was one of those weird ones where
you didn't know if it was like the
richard gere journal story because that
real,
you know what I mean?
Like I had heard that bill cosby does
this to women like,
okay,
I don't know,
it's so beyond the pale that feels like,
and you don't.
And then,
but then you know,
when it's 50 women that come out and say
drug them go,
okay,
something's going on.
Becomes clear.
And the problem is,
it becomes,
in a case like that,
what would have to be true for the
stories to be false is pretty extreme.
But yeah.
So,
um,
well it's also him.
There's evidence of him mocking drugging
people.
I mean,
he,
he did an episode of the cosby show
where he drug people.
He did.
He would talk about it on talk shows
about drugging girls.
I mean,
he most likely was guilty.
Oh,
I think there's no question and you
don't need to.
You don't need the due process.
And this crazy.
If it was the most complicated
conspiracy of all time,
of all these gals got together and said,
I know we should do it.
Make some noise.
Let's,
I'll make up the same story for decades
ago.
There was,
there would be some sort of evidence of
that.
So,
so in this case,
and in harvey weinstein's case,
and I think in matt lauer's case,
the evidence is so overwhelming that it
overrides our need as members of the
public to see,
to,
to withhold judgment until due process
has unfolded.
But the point is,
there's a place at which that stops
right at which things are murky enough
that you have to wait for due process
and the idea that this movement is
actually not really interested in due
process and it's in fact it challenged
his due process and says you have to
believe victims,
right?
Asking for evidence is augmenting the
problem is victim blaming or,
or whatever.
Um,
thIs is a terrible error.
And so if we are to get to a state that
makes sense,
it has to be one in which monsters are
held to account in which there's nuance
and degrees of guilt and that we don't
throw everybody out piece.
Some people can't.
And I can't imagine that bill cosby can
be rehabilitated.
But could al franken be rehabilitated?
If that's the story?
Maybe he could be.
Yeah.
There's a thing where we get to a
certain age where we no longer thing
people can grow.
Right?
And like if he was 20 avow frank and
took that picture when he was 20 and
we'd be like,
that's silly kid.
What is he doing?
That's not something that's appropriate.
What if that was your mom,
mom swore,
and then you learn and you grow,
but for those of us who I'm value
liberty,
a situation in which we re organize the
entire landscape to make sex with
strangers as safe as it can possibly be.
That is not a landscape that is good for
everybody.
we need to make a landscape in which
people who want to do that are free to
do it,
but not everybody is compelled to play
that game.
In other words,
people who want to engage in some kind
of courtship that is more nuanced and
frankly fun and deeper and more subtle
are free to engage in that and that
won't be perfectly safe either,
but what we should want is a landscape
in which we generate safety for people
at the level that doesn't cost us
spectacularly in terms of how
civilization functions,
and then we need to actually say also,
and this was a.
This is another tough point where I'm
worried that people will hear it in that
monolithic way,
but the following thing is true.
I believe a woman,
if civilization functioned well,
a woman should be able to put on the
minimum close that the law will allow to
cover herself in oil,
to walk through town in the middle of
the night.
I'm saying things that indicate that
she's hot to trot.
If she can find the right guy and she
should be safe to do it,
but a woman would have to be insane to
do that.
It's not a good thing to do,
so we should want a civilization issues,
legal protection for her to do it.
No sane person should choose to do it
because because people,
because it's no sane person,
would choose to flip bmx bikes on the x
games and no sane person would choose to
jump out of planes,
but we should allow them the right to do
so for that thrill.
I'm going to push back on that a lIttle
bit and say risk taking.
When you are putting yourself at risk
and you aren't involving someone else
who is going to see your signals and
maybe act on them and then is going to
have acted on signals that you shouldn't
have been sending in the first place.
It's different.
So bmx bike jumping out of a plan,
risk taking is a more common in men than
women on average across cultures.
Uh,
not to say that a lot of women don't
take risks and have fun doing it.
Physical risks,
but absolutely as risk taking adaptive
and enjoyable and interesting.
and if you're risk taking results in you
dying and no one else getting hurt,
go for it.
How is the man getting her?
If the woman is taking these risks,
walking on this tree,
oiled up with a bikini on,
yelling out that she's randy.
If there's a chance that later he is
held accountable for the kid that
results or she changed her mind or
whatever it is that the claim is,
especially in
this current climate of believable
women,
that is potentially a problem.
I see what you're saying.
I see where it would be more complicated
than just jumping out of a plane and
parachuting,
but it's still voluntary risk taking,
you know,
you are involved involving another
person who's also voluntarily getting
involved in that.
well,
unfortunately there's no.
There's going to be no set rule that we
can establish that neutralizes these
things.
You know,
you go to disneyland,
I haven't been to disneyland in decades,
but you should go.
It's nice right now.
It's fun place,
but if you go to disneyland,
everything has been rendered perfectly
safe,
right?
People have been through it with a fine
tooth comb so that nothing bad can
happen to you and you can have all of
this excitement on the rides,
but nothing bad is gonna happen to you.
We cannot turn civilization into that
kind of landscape.
The price of turning it into a landscape
in which you can be a moron and walk
through life and nothing bad is gonna
happen to you.
That price is way too high.
This is it actually.
So I mean this,
this thing,
this moment in time in 2018 is a natural
outgrowth of things like helicopter
parenting where you pray,
you keep your children from all possible
danger,
all possible physical risk,
and you then end up with children who
find a fence at and feel unsafe in all
manner of situations.
It is impossible to be an adult if you
don't do trial and error and it's
impossible to become a sexual adult if
you don't engage in some trial and
error.
That involves a little bit of risk and I
don't know.
I don't want physical risk and sexual.
I'M a play,
but there is going to be some
experimenting with those.
There's going to be some even meeting
friends.
Exactly,
exactly.
And some,
and I think the totally non fraught
version of this is that we took our kids
and a 30 undergraduates to the amazon
because that's one of the most
biodiverse places on earth and it's
extraordinary.
And for evolutionary biologist,
why wouldn't you go if you could?
And a lot of our friends thought you're
taking this little boy's amazon.
The first time we took them there were
10 and eight and you know,
we waited,
I wanted,
I wanted to take them sooner.
Uh,
so I was leading the study abroad trips
earlier and brett said they're too
young,
but you know,
basically they're too young for us to
give them the shots that western
civilization has afforded us to give
them,
to,
um,
to keep them safe with things like
yellow fever
too young to deal with the instructions
that you need to actually remain.
So say from jaguars.
Jaguars are not the issue.
It's more like three falls under it's
trees falling on you.
It's water that rises quickly.
Certainly at the point we took them,
we talked to them a lot in advance as we
talked to our students in advance.
And then we trusted them and you know,
our younger son found a gigantic coral
snake at one point and walking ahead of
us on the trail along with the guide
that we happen to have with us.
And he ran back and I'm,
the guide ran forward and actually pin
the snakes so we could see it.
But this,
you know,
that was a danger that that was,
and god forbid something had happened,
it would be very hard for us to live
with ourselves,
had that gone differently,
but you've exposed your children to
risks so that they can then know what to
do in risk happens to them.
You expose yourself to sexual situations
that aren't stranger sex so that you can
know how to build courtship and romance
and love and sex later on,
like friends,
just a trial and error.
Friends.
Yeah.
So there is a,
how do we learn what
we learn in order to manage the world?
Our developmental environments have to
give us model situations that are close
enough to the situations that we run
into as adults that we have the tools to
navigate them.
And so one of the,
uh,
I think very difficult things to accept
as a parent is that if your child is
going to be able to manage risk as an
adult,
they cannot be made perfectly safe as a
child,
which means that you are running the
risk that something disastrous will
happen and that you'll have to live with
it.
If you make your child perfectly safe in
childhood,
they will be terrible at managing risk
as adults and then something terrible is
gonna happen to them.
So,
uh,
what,
what I operate on,
or maybe I'm reverse engineering,
what the way I think I've learned how to
behave is something I call a the theory
of close calls,
which is that you don't want to have
disaster strike.
And in facT,
we've told our children,
we've said,
look,
we don't want you to break your arm or
your leg,
but you may have,
you may end up doing it and you're
allowed to.
Here are the things you're not allowed
to do.
You're not allowed to damage your skull.
You're not allowed to damage your eyes.
You're not allowed to damage your back.
Right?
You protect those who protect those
things at all costs.
And actually when we took the students
to,
uh,
to Ecuador,
we had,
it wasn't really the only rule,
but we called it the one rule and it was
really the central guiding principle of
the trip,
which was 11 week trip through all these
ecosystems and Ecuador.
It's really long extended trip with
students that we knew,
well we had,
we had been with them all year and we
had cultivated community so we knew him
well.
And what we said is,
look,
um,
lots of things are gonna happen.
you're gonna have to navigate on the
fly.
Nobody comes home in a box,
nobody comes home in a box.
And we actually had three close calls on
this trip.
Um,
and people told us actually that when
they experienced serious danger,
this thing actually occurred to them.
Nobody comes home in a box and it was
like sober them up.
But to go back to the theory of close
calls,
you can't learn how not to get run over
by a car,
by getting somewhat run over by a car.
Right?
But you can learn from your close calls.
So I had a,
uh,
a good friend,
actually somebody that.
So heather and I were not dating in high
school,
but we were friends.
We went to the same high school.
Somebody we knew in high school.
It happened to go to the same college
that I started at penn and we were
walking down the street one day and she
stepped into the street thinking it was
clear and this car whizzed by her at 40
miles an hour,
didn't touch her.
Um,
and so the question is,
what do you think about something like
that?
She was unscratched,
but had she been one second ahead of
where she was,
she would have probably been dead.
And so you could think,
well,
I must be doing something right because
I got away with it.
Or you could be thinking the difference
between my death and not being scratched
in this case wasn't something that I did
with any sort of intent.
It was pure luck.
That saved my life right there.
Therefore I need to figure out how it is
that I stepped off that curb without
noticing that that car was coming.
There's something wrong in my model of
how to live that,
that I could have gotten that close.
So as you experienced close calls,
they tell you something about where your
model is broken and you can fix it.
And so I think what heather's getting at
is learning how to interact with other
people,
especially when you're talking about
high stakes stuff like romance and sex.
You need to have some room to figure out
how these relationships are negotiated
and if the point is these rules are
going to be negotiated by some people
who are going to lay down the law and
say you must seek affirmative consent
every 37 seconds.
That's not going to work.
It's not going to teach anyBody how you
actually manage with another human
being.
Makes sense.
And I don't know how you teach that to a
child to manage risk versus reward in
relationships.
I mean,
how,
how do you,
how do you know?
I mean,
one of the things that we hope is that
they gained some sort of an
understanding of human interaction when
they're in their teen years,
when there are still at home,
then they're protected somewhat when
they go to college.
And then as they go out into the world.
Yeah,
it's tough how much information that
they accumulated.
You have to let them,
let them do it and allow them to judge
for god's sake.
There's this don't judge thing going on.
You know they will be.
No,
no,
no exclusion of anyone at any time on
the school yard and don't judge anyone
no matter what they say,
well,
that's bad for the kid that gets judged.
That's because there's some behavior
that sucks and they need to know that
it's very uncomfortable for other people
to be around you when you're like that,
and that's how you understand social
interaction and this is a big part of
how kids grow into adults.
This is how humAns become humans.
It's
not just top down from parents and from
teachers.
It's largely from peers.
I love what you said about helicopter
parenting because I think you're totally
right.
I think that is part of what's going on
here.
I think part of what's going on here
also is this new found ability to
complain and communicate.
It's beautiful in the fact that you
could exchange information at an
incredible pace.
I mean,
we'll never had anything remotely like
this in human history,
but it's terrible.
In the fact that it's hard to figure out
what's noise,
there's so much chatter going on and if
you're a dummy,
you could find other dummies that think
just like you and you organize a very
volatile group and you reinforced
confirmation bias.
You all get together.
We interact on a forum and there's a few
forums that are frequent that are just
filled with.
They're just echo chambers and they're
confusing and like,
I don't know anybody that thinks like
this but are here.
They are all collected,
convinced that there is no biological
difference in the sexes and that a trans
woman is a woman.
If you don't date trans women that
you're a bigot.
You know even if you're a heterosexual
male and she has a penis,
it's.
There's a lot of squirrelly thinking
going on and it's reinforced by others
and you start thinking you're right and
that you are the future and all these
people out there that are living in this
archaic,
ancient way,
they there are artifacts of the past and
they will soon be relegated.
The history.
Well,
there's a summary.
Wasn't good enough there.
there is a a property of our current
lives that people just need to be more
aware of.
We arrive at the present.
We are partially updated by various
features like school for modern
circumstances,
but we are also partially throwbacks and
we aren't throwbacks.
Evolutionary psychology,
in my opinion,
has aired in imagining that we are
simply stone age hunter gatherers
wandering around civilization,
but we are throwbacks to various places
in our past,
some of them recent,
some of them,
much more remote,
and what we face is an epidemic of
novelty.
So novelty Is all of the stuff that we
don't have programming on board to
navigate all of the stuff that your
instincts don't tell you what to do.
The foods you know,
the refined sugar,
the corporation that wants to advertise
the cereal to your child so that they
eat more of it than they should or they
eat different stuff than they would be.
Novelty makes us sick and novelty can
make you physically sick.
It can make you psychologically sick.
It can make you socially sick,
and we can also be the source of great
change.
Evolution can deal with novelty,
but not at the rate of change that is
happening now.
The rate of change is so high that our
evolutionary capacity to deal with
novelty is outstripped.
And so I do want to,
you know,
there is a way in which,
um,
you know,
if you just listened to little sound
soundbites from what we're at,
you could get the wrong idea that were
very traditional and in fact our
relationship isn't traditional at all.
Um,
but I asked him to carry the second
baby,
but he wouldn't do it.
I would after he was born.
That's quite a lot.
But um,
we have not thought carefully about the
fact that porn is effectively
functioning like,
um,
sexuality,
school for kids,
right?
You don't learn about sex in school.
Sex ed is kind of a choke.
People don't take it seriously,
but where do they learn about sex?
Well,
they learned about it from what they
encounter on the internet.
And here's the problem with that.
That is not an honest report of
anything.
What that Is,
is the result of competition,
economic competition between porn
producers to capture your attention.
Right?
So what that means is that it pushes in
the direction of all sorts of stuff that
people might not be that interested in
because this producer wants to take your
attention away from that producer and so
they make something more extreme or
certainly triggers that second male
strategy.
Yeah,
that's what I was going to say.
It's the second male strategy of the no
strings attached.
A person who you could just hook up with
a on a whim.
You're delivering a pizza and she grabs
you by your shirt and pulls you in.
It's like what?
Who?
And that's the norm.
That's the norm.
Yeah.
Bingo.
And so what we've effectively done is
accidentally economically,
we've announced two children that this
is what sex looks like and maybe they
even get proficient at that kind of sex,
but it's mechanical,
uninteresting,
and has very little to do with the most
rewarding stuff in,
in what it is to be a human being,
which has to do with deeper,
long lasting relationships.
So it shouldn't surprise us at all that
we've arrived at a dysfunctional moment
where people are shouting at each other
about what the rules have to be.
Because what we've installed as a
mechanism for learning about these
things is not,
it does not have our interests at heart.
It is an economic entity that is not
under anyone's control.
And it's quite dangerous.
Now,
before the inevitable backlash,
oh my god,
he said porn was bad.
I really do think porn is bad,
right?
I don't think erotica is bad.
If somebody wants to make sexual content
with some purpose other than trying to
grab your attention and take your money,
then that's valid.
and it doesn't mean everybody's got to
be interested in it.
And it doesn't mean that everybody's got
to produce it.
But I don't want to see us prevent
people from making valid sexual
statements that are interesting in
whatever form they take.
I don't necessarily want to see children
exposed to it willy nilly.
But my real point is,
um,
you know,
just as there's a distinction between
the really good stuff that you sometimes
see on your television screen because
somebody put together a well thought out
series and broadcast television,
which is often pretty garbagey.
there's a big difference between the
sort of garbagy view of sex that people
are getting because the economics are
driving us in that direction and some
more interesting nuanced,
uh,
adventurous version that we might see if
the landscape wasn't saturated with the,
um,
the,
uh,
the porn version.
Well,
I'm just to defend porn.
I think there's got to be a spectrum of
porn.
I'm not a porn investigator,
but I would imagine that there's some
romantic couple porn that makes sense
where it is a husband and wife or
boyfriend and girlfriend and the video
or boy and boy or whatever the fuck you
want.
But what,
what it is,
is natural and healthy.
There's got to be a market for that.
I can't all be extreme crazy stuff
that's just designed to get your
attention.
I mean,
it must.
I think there is,
but I think it's,
I think it's miscategorized.
So I mean of,
well I'm not really interested in porn
so I don't know what's out there,
but my understanding is that actually
there are many people who are producing
amateur stuff and maybe they have an
exhibitionist streak or something,
but that there is,
you know,
human beings are naturally fascinated by
human human sex.
Yeah.
That's a big category I believe is
couples like amateur couples and some
people actually prefer that because it
seems like real people who were
attracted to each other actually having
sex because it might actually have some
information in it.
And it might be,
you know,
fRankly it might be more exciting
because it has some reality to it.
But my point iS,
you know,
there's a gray area,
I would say the distinction between porn
and erotic is actually pretty easy to
draw and it has to do with whether the
motivation that caused it to be produced
is economic.
Right.
If the motivation that caused it to be
produced,
if it would not have been produced
absent that economic motivation,
it's porn and I'm suspicious of it.
So 50 shades of grey as porn then I
haven't seen it.
Good for you.
Neither have I.
It's just,
it's erotic radical.
If none of the female.
Let's let's talk about.
Yeah,
let's definitely cast judgment.
Yeah.
Yep.
I see what you're saying.
Um,
and I,
I definitely agree that it's school set
sex school for children and there's a
giant issue in that because it is an
unrealistic depiction of actual sexual
interaction for the most part,
like most sexual encounters are not
going to go the way they are in porn and
just like setting your kid in front of a
screen when he or she is really young.
Mom does not teach that kid how to
interact with real human beings.
Right.
If porn is your exposure to sex,
it's going to create a kind of sex
autism,
like
you're not gonna know how to engage with
actual real human beings who can give
you feedback.
That's interesting.
Way to describe it.
Yeah.
I liked that.
I mean it's a little,
it's a little dangerous obviously
because.
Well for various reasons,
but,
but just from the point of view that it
denies you a sense of what the
feedback's would look like because
feedbacks between two people don't look
like what happens when somebody writes a
script.
It's not universal.
It's not generalizable.
Do you know the very nature of human
interaction?
Is that it's one off?
Do you think it's something along the
lines.
I mean obviously.
See here's the problem with porn.
One of the problems with porn is because
of the accessibility is so high.
It's not like x rated a violent movies
or used to be.
They used to be.
Some movies were x rated for violence.
Remember that?
Or nc?
17.
Right?
Um,
but you,
you could be 13 with a cell phone and
you have access to all the poor of the
world.
And I just think,
yeah,
so many of these issues I think know we
need to be nuanced and very careful once
we're talking about adults when people
become adults as a question.
But when we're talking about clearly
still kids,
you know,
should children be exposed to porn?
No.
They are still developing.
They're still figuring out how to be
adults should,
should children be given sex hormones of
the sex that they are not born to.
Even if they might end up transitioning
and becoming translator on almost
certainly not because the vast number of
people who end up realizing,
oh actually I was experimenting.
This is what,
this is what childhood is.
I was trying on something else and now
I've made it permanent by virtue of
medicalizing the thing.
Yeah,
you're there.
That's another subject entirely,
but I completely agree.
You're,
you're essentially making a permanent
decision for a trial as early as.
I mean,
I've heard it argued three years old,
which is insane.
Yeah.
It just doesn't seem to.
It doesn't seem to suit.
It doesn't seem to fit any logic.
The only thing that seems to fit is this
agenda,
that this is a natural,
normal part of our society in which you
reinforce it as early as possible.
Well,
I want to push back on that a little
bit.
I think it's very clear there's so much,
um,
gender confusion that sorts itself out
through the natural process of
development that the idea that we should
intervene medically when we have no idea
who is going to grow out of it and who's
going to transition if,
and I don't think we will ever be there
because of the nature of human
development,
but if it were possible to know who
actually was committed to this road and
going to transition than there is an
argument to be made that the earlier
that they transition,
the more completely they are able to
jump the gap.
And so the precautionary principle has
to apply here.
That,
you know,
trans trans is a real condition and some
people have it and should be allowed to
transition,
but allowing children to make that
decision for themselves when more than,
more often than not they end up not
transitioning is frankly,
it looks criminal too.
I think in the,
in the modern situation with how little
we understand about why it is that some
people end up a gender dysphoric for
life and all of that.
There is no way that we should be a
inner interfering early.
You have to let children sort this stuff
out.
I'm just saying in the abstract,
it's not that there's no argument for
doing it early.
It's at the argument for doing it early
doesn't come anywhere near the strength
to the argument for not doing it early,
which is that these things sort
themselves out and actually if you
really have been born into the wrong
body,
know as,
as is the phrase that is used by,
um,
by people.
Some of them will have known who are
actually legitimately trans.
The earlier the hormonal inputs came in,
the more fully they would be able to
transition.
You have a more.
They drank,
the risk is too high.
The risk is it,
it's
unconscionable.
Now,
isn't that a,
it's so we're,
we're into some strange blind territory.
When you start saying legitimately
trans,
like who was illegitimately trans?
If you decided we trans,
you're legitimately trans people who are
wearing it as a,
as a fashion statement.
How could you discuss how,
how can anyone make that distinction if
they're not that person?
I don't,
I don't.
I don't know if that's,
I don't know if that's true.
Um,
I,
I would,
I bet you're right.
I'm not disagreeing with you,
but how would we know?
I think,
you know,
because the cost of being trans in a
society that views trans the way ours
does is so high that there is a
very,
it's a barrier to telling the world that
this is how you feel is substantial
enough to prevent people from.
I'm flirTing with it
casually.
I would push back on that because
there's people that get face tattoos and
they do weird body modifications.
It's looked down upon constantly.
People do a lot of things for self hate
purposes.
They do a lot of things to shock people.
They do a lot of things because they
just want to get a reaction out of
people.
I don't necessarily agree with that.
I think you might,
you might be right,
that there are people that wear it as a
fashion statement,
but who are people who have assumed
traditional or semi traditional gender
roles to make that distinction?
Well,
if we believe in real freedom,
I think we have to let people choose.
I think we can for sure children choose,
we can't let,
we certainly can't let parents leap to
it.
And so heather has said a number
so people don't know how they should
know that she
is a dyed in the wool toMboy and has
been a for her whole life.
She,
uh,
since I was destroying the frilly
dresses,
my mother was putting me destroying the
frilly dresses and resenting the pink
color that your room was painted.
Um,
but um,
so you essentially a modeled yourself
after your dad.
Your dad was a computer scientist,
one of the early pioneers in operating
system,
a authorship and uh,
anyway,
heather and her had a very strong
relationship with her dad and she played
like a boy and I'm.
Heather has asked things.
He said to me on several occasions was I
will not raise a weak girl.
I will not raise a hopeless or helpless
child.
And so,
you know,
when I,
when I'd have my nose buried in a book
and he'd be out back building a fence,
you're going to come out and help me dig
postholes and pour the cement and put
the,
put in the posts and you're going to do
this,
not because I expect that you're going
to go into fence building,
uh,
but because you need to know how to work
with your hands and do physical work in
the universe and see what the
ramifications are.
Not that he didn't want you reading the
book.
Oh,
of course not.
Yeah.
I mean he,
you know,
he on other weekends he was taking me to
a math competition.
So you know,
there was a lot of abstraction and,
and play with numbers and science as
well in sport.
But it was specifically about not
assuming what I was going to be capable
of because I was born a girl.
that's
a giant problem with this category of
men and women.
Obviously there's this giant spectrum
inside each category and that should be
okay.
It should be all right.
It means to be okay.
It has to be,
it has to,
and this is one of the problems with
assuming traditional gender roles or
assuming types of behavior and what some
people like sexually,
other people would hate and vice verse
and some people.
I mean some people can get away with
things because women find it attractive.
Whereas another man could do the exact
same thing and women who think it's
disgusting and that's okay too.
Well,
we have to err in the direction of
keeping people safe,
but we can't turn the dial on safety to
11 because it will destroy everything
else will till all the fun.
What,
what is it?
I can't imagine that these categories
are invariant,
right?
That male looks one way and I mean this
is exactly what you're saying,
but it's,
it's,
you know,
they,
many of the people who are arguing
against the biology of sex and gender
say things like gender isn't binary and
they're right.
It's not,
but it's,
it's bi-modal.
These are,
these are population distributions with
a lot of variation in them and they're
widely overlapping,
but that doesn't mean that the same
identical,
but they are broadly overlapping.
They certainly do.
Right,
and there's been some interesting
pushback from these older european
women,
particularly french women who are like,
what the fuck are you guys doing?
You're ruining sex romance in courtship
and exactly.
They have a different attitude about it
and they think that there's a certain
amount of aggressive behavior from men
that they enjoy and they don't want to
douse that.
Well.
So somehow this.
I'm glad we're getting to thiS part of
the conversation.
One thing to say is I didn't finish the
thing that heather is that heather has
vocalized that if she grew up in the
modern era,
she worries that somebody,
her parents wouldn't have.
They would have fought back,
but that some people would have been
thinking,
oh,
you're trans.
We need to,
we need to take care of you and we need
to give you hormones and things like
that.
Because the fact that she played like a
boy would have been taken as an
indication that she was born in the
wrong body or something.
And so that can't happen.
We have to protect people so that they
can sort out their own stuff in it.
So I mean we have to expand and it
really feel like we had already kind of
gotten here,
but I've talked to people who identify
as trans who say things like,
I'm trans because I don't fit into my
father's mold of a macho man and I
prefer to read poetry and to which I
say,
that's terrific.
Okay,
be that man and then that that if,
if that is the extent of why you were
calling yourself trans,
I don't think that makes you trans.
Isn't there an issue and this is not.
I'm not anti any of this,
but isn't there an issue with saying
that who you really truly are is
dependent upon you getting injections of
hormones that are not native to your
body?
Isn't that very odd that we've taken
synthetic hormones and made them an
integral part of who a person is?
Now again,
I'm not saying you shouldn't be able to
do it.
You certainly should be able to do it,
but it's oddly almost a biologically
essentialist push perspective coming
from people who are denying biology.
But here's this thing that I'm saying.
If you are who you are,
why is no one willing to accept who they
are in this situation and instead wants
to or not.
I shouldn't say no one is a bad way of
phrasing it.
Why is it assumed that if you do feel
like you were born in the wrong body,
the only way to change that is to inject
hormones that are not native to your
body,
to have surgery,
to alter yourself,
to assume traditional gender dress and
look of the opposite sex.
Like there's like,
there's a lot of people that pushed back
against women sexualiZing themselves,
but celebrate trans women sexualizing
themselves to look more like women
because they think this is a feeling of
empowerment for these women that look
how beautiful they are.
You go girl,
look at those legs like there's this
thing about it where it's like,
it's celebrated as this merging of your
true self.
This,
this is one of these places I believe we
have at least a one way failure and
maybe a two way failure of empathy,
right?
So,
um,
I've spent,
you know,
we,
we have lots of history with trans
students who,
you know,
at first I must say there's a lot of
trans folks at evergreen and at first
when we first arrived it was odd to me.
Like what percentage?
Well that is a hard question because
when you ask people to self report,
the number is absurdly high but I don't
certainly high like it's so I that it is
reported as 40 percent at evergreen,
which,
which doesn't really make any 48,
four,
zero,
four 0:40,
which you can't really can't be the
case,
which is part of why I say some people
are trying it on trying it on as an
identity as opposed to any of that.
That includes lgb but it's,
it's too high.
When they gravitate though towards the
school like that,
that so minded they would.
But you know,
we have an intuitive sense by just the
population when people are faking it.
Well,
no,
I'm not saying that at all,
but I'm saying that there's like a,
a desire to affirm a folks in this
category and so placing yourself,
I'd rather than faking it,
I would say people who don't agree with
the gender norms associated with that,
the gender they were born to run
themselves trans.
And to me that doesn't look like trans.
That's,
that's a,
that's a misrepresentation of what trans
is because we've also known many
students who are really legitimately
transcend,
have done surgery or hormones or both
and are and are better off in their
bodies and more at peace with themselves
having done so.
Um,
so I think it is very hard to appreciate
a,
we are all in some sense not well by
virtue of the fact that we live in a
civilization that is not a good match
for,
um,
for what we bring to the table even are
the environments we grew up in.
His children do not match our adult
environments.
And so we don't intubate them well.
And that causes all kinds of health
issues,
psychological and otherwise,
when people find themselves in this
predicament that we are calling trans,
they have access to a remedy.
I mean,
imagine it's just put yourself in the
mindset of somebody who feels like they
should have been a woman.
You know,
mind you,
I'm now learning that some trans people
actually don't feel this way,
that feeling like you were born in the
wrong body.
It's not a universal,
it's very commonly said,
but it is not universal.
But imagine that,
that that is how you felt.
You felt like you were being addressed
as a man.
You were being understood as a man,
but that's not how you internally felt
and there was access to something,
some set of things that would cause the
world to finally register you as you
felt you were right.
It would be very tempting to avail
yourself of that stuff.
And I think it's hard for those of us
who feel at home enough in the bodies
that were in to appreciate what the
pressure must be like.
If there is something available to you
to go for it and to cross that gap and I
also think it's creating a problem as
we're trying to discuss issues like
sexual signaling and makeup and high
heels and things as people have been
discussing.
ThiS causes a special problem for trans
folks,
for a trans women because in many cases,
maybe almost all cases they are using
these signs that are,
and I don't want to get in trouble here.
These makeup is well understood to
amplify sexual signaling and is not the
only role is playing,
is not inherently conscious.
It is not inherently intended to be
triggering everybody broadly,
but nonetheless,
makeup high heels.
These,
um,
mechanisms for amplifying a certain set
of signals are being used by trans folks
as a mechanism for amplifying their sex.
In other words,
if somebody puts on a whole bunch of
makeup in order to send a signal that
they are looking for a mate,
let's say.
I'm not saying everybody who puts on
makeup is doing that,
but somebody might put on makeup in
order to attract male attention.
That's one kind of signal.
But if you're trans,
you may put on that makeup in order to
send a signal.
I am female,
right?
So you're sending a signal that is of a
very different nature.
And so I think there is a way in which
trans people are feeling backed against
the wall by a discussion that is now
very clumsily happening about these
mechanisms of sexual signaling because
it puts them in a particular predicament
where they're feeling like they're about
to be robbed of the very stuff that
allows them to,
uh,
to accentuate their femininity does very
well put.
Yeah.
I think that's a very important
distinction to,
especially when you're talking about
someone who's trying to self affirm.
Yeah.
Right.
Now,
one of the things that came up real
recently was this Jordan Peterson
interview with vice,
which in my opinion,
especially when you look at the sound
clip,
they were talking about women in the
workplace and women wearing makeup and
high heels and things in the workplace.
And I know Jordan very well.
I love him.
He's a great guy.
He came off aggressive there and I don't
know why I don't.
I don't know if he's tired of it or if
he's digging his heels in.
I mean,
he's apparently part of a two hour
interview.
I kind of felt like he was on the ropes
the whole time.
Yes.
And he also coming off of that big kathy
newman interview in the uk,
which was like an assault.
I mean the whole thing was just crazy,
but he came out ahead on that and I
think,
um,
there's,
it's much easier to make the argument
that he didn't come out ahead and the
vice thing,
especially in the way that they framed
it,
but he was talking about women in the
workplace and maybe women shouldn't wear
makeup in the workplace and maybe they
shouldn't wear high heels or dresses.
So hE did say maybe,
maybe.
Yes,
he did.
He didn't say women shouldn't do this.
The interviewer,
I can't remember his name,
king king j king maybe said so do you
think women shouldn't wear makeup and
high heels then?
And he said,
maybe.
Yeah.
And it was,
you know,
he's,
he's thinking he's,
he's considering options here.
He's not prepared upon first being asked
a question to say yes,
absolutely or no.
Absolutely.
This is,
you know,
this is a sign of a nuanced thinking
person.
Yes,
brain in action in real time.
The problem with the reaction is the
exact problem that you're trying to
avoid here though when you're saying,
I don't want to get in trouble here,
you,
you preface that and then you slowly
move forward.
Whereas Jordan was like,
maybe,
well,
why are they wearing makeup?
But what did they do?
But I would say that,
you know,
the generous interpretation and the
evolutionary interpretation of what he
said was,
look,
the me too movement is arguing that
there should be,
that there can be no sexual signals in
the workplace at all.
Full Stop.
that's not going to be possible because
look at how many other sexual signals
there are makeup heels.
Now the response has been,
those aren't sexual signals.
I wear heels and I'm not sexually
signaling and you know,
to which the evolutionary response is
what heals do is augment sexual signals
that you were born with.
Whether or not you're conscious of the
fact that that is why you were doing it,
that doesn't make it any less of a
sexual signal.
right,
and so what peterson was saying was if
we really are going to accept the
argument that all signals of this type
need to be abandoned from you need to be
gotten rid of from the workplace,
then maybe we actually need to
investigate all of the other things that
are sexual signals that aren't being
talked about right now.
So there are a couple things.
First of all,
have you seen the
clip filmed from the audience of him
talking about what happened with that
vice interview?
No.
It's well worth your time.
I think it's seven or eight minutes of
him talking about what happened.
I do think peterson who I also know,
I don't think I can give you the cliff
notes of what.
Yeah,
I mean the cliff notes are.
He said,
look,
this is how one engages in,
fought one advances an idea.
It doesn't mean something's going to
happen.
I think he literally says,
I didn't say women shouldn't wear in the
workplace.
I said,
maybe,
and this is what we do,
and then he describes,
he says,
um,
let's,
let's agree that I'm going to put
forward 10 things that might happen and
then let's agree that none of them are
going to happen.
So now we can discuss the possibilities.
So I don't think we know what the actual
interview with jay kang looked like
because there was two hours of it and
I've seen 15 minutes.
Yeah.
Why won't they release more of it?
I think they should release the whole
thing.
I do think what I saw.
So we don't know the context,
which my guess is a peterson's pretty
careful in what he says.
My guess is the context would be
revealing.
I think based on the part that we know
that he said because it is in the clips
that we've seen.
We know something's funny because the
editing juxtaposes him seeming to
contradict himself and he's actually
pretty careful not to do that.
Um,
but what he did actually say contains
what I regard as at least one
significant error.
So he says,
uh,
I do think that in response to the
question of our women hypocrites for
wearing makeup to work and then,
uh,
I don't want to put words in his mouth,
but something like demanding not to be
harassed,
harassed or something like that.
So he's forgetting that many of these
signals aren't conscious and not only
doing that,
not conscious,
but you know,
I saw somebody online discussing this.
They made a very good point when it's
actually pretty hard to field if these
are signals,
even unconscious ones,
if they are sexual signals,
why am I wearing one to go to a family
reunion?
WhY am I wearing high heels to go to a
family reunion?
I am.
I secretly trying to get lucky at my own
family reunion.
Um,
and the answer is no.
This is not a matter what,
what peterson said when,
you know,
peterson has done so many interviews.
The fact that he says at clumsy thing
here doesn't strike me one way or the
other,
but I don't want to be put in the
position of defending that women are
hypocritical for wearing makeup and high
heels.
there are lots of reasons that you have
to wear them,
including social pressure,
including the fact that you are in a
landscape of other people wearing them,
and if you stand out as being playing in
a world of other women who are
amplifying these things,
that may actually have implications for
your ability to earn.
So there are lots of reasons that you
might do it that have nothing to do With
you as an individual trying to signal
for sexual attention.
It doesn't mean that those things didn't
evolve as sexual signals,
right?
Sexual signals to us,
evolutionary biologists.
This is no news.
I mean,
if you're a woman and you've got breasts
and you're walking around in the world,
you're broadcasting a sexual signal and
that one is completely unconscious and
involuntary physiological,
right?
So the idea that these signals are out
there and common should be,
should become something we become
comfortable with the fact that males are
involved in all kinds of signaling all
the time that,
that,
uh,
the corner office,
the mahogany desk,
and you know,
it's not that a woman can't have a
corner office and my desk,
but traditionally speaking,
those hallmarks of a statue acquisition,
yes,
those things have implication in the
sexual landscape.
That's very powerful as does frankly,
humor.
The way humor is used has powerful
implications in terms of sexual
signaling,
as does who laughs at your jokes.
I mean,
if the boss makes a joke,
everybody laughs whether or not it's
funny.
Why is that?
He's got power.
They're trying to get ahead.
So we can't get rid of all of this.
We can't get rid of.
And if we look at something like an
engagement ring,
right?
If you were to analyze an engagement
ring anthropologically,
right?
So there are these stones.
Actually the truth of it is there these
stones that aren't really that rare,
but they've been made artificially
scarce and a man will get one of these
stones.
And he will put it on a thing that can
be put on a woman's finger and the size
of the stone and the quality of the
stone,
even though the stone is not actually
useful for very much.
It is symbolically important and it is
evidence of the woman's worth in some
sense.
In other words,
the larger the stone indicates that the
man values her at a greater level of
this is an absurd,
an absurd set of signals.
And we treat it as if it's just nothing.
You know,
a woman gets an engagement ring,
maybe if she's traditional or friends
will look at it and say,
oh,
that's marvelous.
I mean,
so we're engaged in all of this archaic
signaling anyway.
And when you tune into it,
it is very jarring.
But it does not make sense to isolate
one set of these signals and say,
oh look,
they're signaling right?
Because those signals are embedded in a
landscape of signals that we go through
our entire life not realizing that we
are making.
A last poInt I would make is that we
also need to recognize that we have a
mismatch between personal signaling and
broadcast signaling.
So it may be that a woman wears
something in order to catch a particular
male's attention,
but the fact that she's wearing it may
catch other male's attention and that
fact may confuse the landscape because,
um,
men in general may take it as a sign
that she's interested in something when
in fact she's not interested in
something.
She's interested in someone who happens
to be in this landscape.
So what I hope is that we will recognize
that the thing that we should all agree
on is that it is desirable to have the
freedom to engage life as you would
engage us as long as you're not harming
others.
You should be.
You know,
I do not think a polyamorous folks are
on the right track.
I think that what they're up to is.
I mean,
I know from the ones who are serious
about it and talk about it,
that even within the polyamorous
community,
there's a recognition about just how
difficult it is to make it work.
Um,
but I don't really want to interfere
with their right to do it.
I would like to be able to talk about
whether it's a good idea,
whether it has societal implications
that we should be aware of,
but body,
I feel like they're not on the right
track and isn't everyone's track.
I mean,
if we can accept trans folk and we can
accept a women to subscribe to cultural
norms and wearing high heels and make up
in the workplace,
why can't we accept polyamorous behavior
and what's.
So that's what I'm telling you.
Is That difficult though?
I personally would counsel somebody if
you know,
and I have had this conversation with
many students,
for example,
um,
I would counsel them away from it
because I think it actually prioritizes
one thing which is desirable,
but that the cost of it is very,
very high.
Um,
and what does it prioritize?
It prioritizes not locking yourself into
a single sexual relationship.
And I think there's a way in which there
is a terror that surrounds locking
yourself into a single sexual
relationship.
And part of the tara goes back to what
we were talking about at the beginning
of the conversation.
If you think that,
um,
beauty max is maxed out at 20 and then
it wanes over live then as a woman,
you're trapped in this terrible
situation where you've got this power
long before you know what to do with it
and it's going to evaporate,
see better capitalize on it.
And if you're a man,
you're very frightened that you're going
to get into a relationship and then
you're going to watch this person that
you love fall apart in front of your
eyes and you're going to be,
you know,
you're going to be caught in that
situation.
And I don't think this is the reality of
a pair bond.
I think the reality of a pair bond is
way better than we fear,
but that because we've got this overly
simplistic mythology surrounding it,
a lot of people are trying to solve that
problem.
How do I not get locked into that
relationship that's going to trap me
with somebody who's had do not get bored
and decaying in front of me,
right?
Um,
yeah,
I don't think it's a decaying thing.
I would push back against that.
I would say people just want more
variety.
They just want,
they're attracted to other people and
they want to act on that and if they
find a partner who's also willing to do
that and they stay together,
I don't see what would be the issue if
they wanted to do it.
Well,
I'm,
I'm telling you specifically that I
don't want to stop them from doing it,
but I do want people to think very
carefully about the issues.
I mean,
I'm just speaking as one guy who's lived
one life,
um,
the value that I get out of,
having as close to perfect security at
home as I can have in a relationship.
I mean,
heather and I have been all over the
world.
We've taken our kids into parts of the
amazon that are four hours by boat from
the nearest road.
Right.
This is not a boring relationship.
This relationship has been a nonstop
adventure.
Right?
But no one's trying to push polyamory on
you.
Well,
a,
I wouldn't say that that's true.
I would say that the bar,
not as an individual,
but what I would say is they are
promoting an idea that this is the
sophisticated way to live.
It's the wave of the future if they.
Yeah.
And that it common is this,
this,
this.
Well,
I mean you mentioned sex at dawn
yourself.
and so the idea is,
but chris is my friend and he's crazy.
There you go.
But what I would say leaves it.
He might be right.
I'm does believe it.
And I,
you know,
fortunately it is right.
I have been convinced by a,
a friend who I had a long standing
argument with on this topic and what he
convinced me is that a friend who is
polyamorous,
yes,
a friend who is polyamorous and this
friend has convinced me that it can be
accomplished,
that there's somewhere to get.
But he acknowledges that it actually,
um,
in the case that he points to took
several generations.
I'm literally several generations to
arrive at a stable a situation.
Well,
you guys have a wonderful relationship
though.
I know many people who have terrible,
terrible relationships.
And for them,
the notion of monogamy seems absurd.
It seems like a trap.
You get stuck in,
you grow to resent each other,
and then he gets sick of each other and
then you fight in court until you figure
out who gets all the money.
Totally.
I would say,
yeah,
those people shouldn't be together.
I think you're right.
Yeah.
But then there's a conflation between
polyamory and promiscuity,
right?
That just a free for all a sex with
strangers free for all is different from
the kind of careful approach to
polyamory that this friend takes,
which still looks extraordinarily
difficult to pull off,
given what human beings are from a
jealousy perspective,
it isn't monogamy externally difficult
to pull off.
I mean is the rate of divorce in this
country alone.
It's somewhere around 50 percent.
And chris rock famously said that's just
50 percent who had the courage to leave.
How many coward still but here.
But this is.
This is part of the point about novelty.
We are living in a situation where our
narratives sell us a false picture of
our opportunities.
Our narratives are partially driven by
an economy that wants us to be insecure
enough to spend money like crazy.
Um,
and so I'm not telling people that they
should live one way or the other.
I'm telling them that they should
understand what their real options are.
And polyamory as an experiment is all
well and good,
but what happens when you introduce
children into the mix?
Right?
That's very,
very different.
It's very different because children are
so costly to raise and because human
males are wired to fear raising
offspring that they themselves did not
produce genetically.
Now I don't think it makes sense to
actually care very much about your genes
and advancing their interests.
I think this is something evolution has
stuck us with that is not valuable.
It's actually destructive,
but nonetheless eventually move past.
But we are wired for it.
And so what I'm expecting to happen is
if you have a large scale experiment in
polyamory,
what it's going to do is it is going to
break down into polygyny and it's going
to break down into single motherhood.
As men leave these relationships in
order to engage in perhaps more
polyamory with younger women and it's
going to be yet one more thing that is a
unevenly distributed between the sexes.
So choose your mate wisely.
Well,
choose your mate wisely,
but we don't even realize that we are
interfering with your ability to do that
in ways that we don't.
Um,
we don't intuit.
We have a landscape in which nobody is
paying attention to the way we are
interfering in the normal processes that
would cause you to find a mate with whom
you might have a very rewarding,
uh,
what lifelong processes are you
referring to all?
Let me take an absurd one.
Okay.
We have no idea what effect deodorant is
having on us.
Choosing the right mate.
We do know that in studies that there
are molecules that you can't consciously
tell you're detecting that do affect
mate choice and we know that we're
interfering with that stuff.
Well,
we know that birth control affects that
as well as well.
Women's fertility specifically women's
ability to smell whether or not she's
even genetically compatible with the
man.
Absolutely.
And was really freaky.
It's like those lizards,
how do they know?
No rubbing up against each other.
So I think I think what to wear.
Deodorant.
A.
I try not to at the moment I'm wearing
it because sweat stains would be
socially.
Oh,
you're wearing.
You're wearing anti person.
I guess I am.
Yeah.
I guess I do important distinction
there.
That's dangerous.
But here this is taking up your poor.
This is a great.
This is a great example because I
actually did spend a,
I don't know if it was a year as an
experiment,
not wearing deodorant.
How'd that go?
Well,
he was already married,
so a couple of interesting facts.
One,
it did drive some people crazy.
I'm sure.
I'm not me though.
Not.
You didn't drive,
you didn't bother you at all?
I'm gonna leave all been around people
we love who at some point we're like
take a shower,
but yeah.
No,
but
as long as you took a shower.
Well actually the thing is though is
shave the armpits thing.
Like if you shave your armpits,
do you see?
It's the one spot,
right?
We're not putting deodorant anywhere
else on our body.
We're just putting it on the armpits,
like is it the shaving thing I'll give
you shave your armpits.
If you shave your armpits,
you decrease the rate at which it
diffuses into the environment.
So it should make a judgment call.
Well,
but in some sense,
look,
I don't know which it is.
Maybe we're being
wusses right,
and we're being,
you know,
we've got an industry of I don't know
how much they make per year selling us
these things because we're afraid of our
own human smell.
Right.
But there's a huge difference between
the way somebody smells if they don't
have good hygiene and somebody who has
the luxury of daily showers and doesn't
wear shorter and frankly I don't find
somebody who is taking daily showers and
isn't wearing deodorant.
I don't find it that off putting.
And in europe it's considered much less
a different smell.
You smell them as opposed to smelling
right guard or whatever it is.
Exactly.
And so anyway,
I,
I have no idea whether if we backed our
deodorant and antiperspirant stuff off,
whether it would change who ended up
with whom and whether or not marriage is
with a small degree of change,
but how many other things are there on
the list that we wouldn't think to name?
What about makeup into women stopped
wearing makeup?
how much would that change?
Who hooks up with who?
How much would it.
And you know,
if we.
How much would it change if we actually
learned that there's a difference
between hotness and beauty and we
actually allowed little girls to
recognize that maybe they weren't so
interested in being hot because although
it gets you a lot of attention,
it's a kind of attention.
That's a dead end,
right?
How much would that change?
Who ends up with whom?
I mean a lot of who ends up with whom at
the moment is presumably dictated by
people having had their attention
captured through hotness.
And then there's a question of whether
there's anything there to back it up.
So what I want to see for my own kids'
sake is I want to see a world in which
the noise of the way the market
influences how we interact with each
other and the notions that get promoted
as sophisticated,
where that noise is reduced so that
people can really begin to detect the
patterns in their life.
Actually,
this worked for me.
I dated in this way and this worked for
me.
I dated in that way and it didn't work
for me.
it wasn't rewarding.
And that begins to tell you something
and all I'm saying about my own
situation.
Yes,
I'm incredibly lucky to have a
relationship that's really rewarding and
you know,
it's a lifelong bond.
On the other hand,
it may say something.
We got together early.
I felt weird about that for a long time.
I felt like it suggested something.
You hear about people getting together
in high school and was like,
oh,
that's cute,
but you know how,
how well you have chosen in high school.
Right?
Well,
I met heather in high school.
We were friends.
We knew each other pretty well by the
time we got together.
And you know,
I was,
I was a dumb kid in my early twenties at
the point that the relationship began,
but it had an advantage that I didn't
necessarily know to think about,
which is heather and I have spent all of
that time.
I'm adventuring together and that means
that instead of looking for the perfect
partner who's exactly the right fit for
you,
to people who had the right starting
material sort of grew together into a
partnership.
The growing together,
apart together.
Yeah.
That'S a,
that's a big part.
And there's a lot of people that don't
spend a lot of time with their mates,
you know,
and you know,
people grow apart to.
You guys get lucky.
Yeah,
that's true.
A lot of friends that are living in
hell.
Yeah,
that's terrible.
It's unfortunately really common.
It's more common than not.
You guys are the outliers role of
scientists taking your kids to the
jungle.
Well,
not the most common thing,
but.
Okay.
Here's the thing.
I don't know because I've only lived one
life,
but I think there is a lesson because I
think that what we did actually was
fairly simple,
which was we played it by ear and the
stuff that didn't work,
we chucked it and the stuff that did
work,
we augmented it and so there are no hard
and fast rules.
Yeah.
You're also exceptional people.
You're both very unusually smart and
openminded well thanks to each other,
but we found each other and I think,
I think openminded display important
than smart in this case.
I like being able to look at each other.
Let's compassion.
You know,
this is true for any interaction,
right?
Let's.
Can I look at unc,
you as a human being with real emotions
and feelings and reality to your
experiences as well.
Even if I feel like we disagree
completely so even,
you know,
even when we're at our angriest with
each other,
if we can see each other's humanity
through it and you get through that,
that is a lesson for every human being
in all walks of life.
In any situation,
when you disagree with someone,
not just your lover,
not just a friend,
but people that you don't even know,
it's.
It's very easy to dehumanize someone who
disagrees with you,
and I think to bring this all back
around,
this is a part of the problem with male
female interaction today is this
dehumanization on both sides,
that the men are demons,
that the woman are this and the men of
that,
and it's all this.
You know,
these rash generalizations in this
extreme tribalism.
Well,
yes,
there is kind of a secret weapon and I.
It's not a secret.
The secret is heather and I have a whole
second channel on which to navigate,
which is that we both know the same
evolutionary story.
Yeah,
so there's a way,
you know.
Here's an idea that's important.
You can very often understand more about
a given human interaction,
especially a contentious one.
If you turn down the sound right,
so you can't hear what's being said,
and that sounds wrong,
right?
Sounds like,
well,
maybe the most important piece of
information you could have is what these
people are saying to each other as
they're arguing,
but no,
that's not how human beings work.
Sometimes the important information is
on that vocal channel and sometimes the
vocal channel is actually almost purely
noise.
Right,
and so if both literally and
metaphorically,
but if heather and I both know that,
then there's a part of us that's sort of
always outside if we.
I mean we don't fight that much.
It's really pretty rare,
but when we do,
there's also a part of us that's
watching the interaction and knows that
a certain pattern may have to unfold in
order for us to get to the other part of
it.
Sometimes heather notes that you're
engaging in theater at some level even
though neither of us wants to be.
That's a great way to put it.
Engaging in couples theater.
It is,
and it is.
It's actually,
it's the perfect example of this thing
like you know,
you're talking about peterson and go
into work and wearing makeup and you
think,
am I sending sexual signals?
Will,
gosh,
we're all involved in weird stuff,
right?
The idea that you and your mate could
both be aware that your argument is in
some,
in some way theater and that even though
you might think,
well,
if it's theater,
we can just skip it now.
You can't know.
There are things that have to happen in
order for you to get to the next act.
And so you know,
they're like,
I hope I'm not saying something I
shouldn't,
but there's a,
there's a thing I'm not the easiest guy
to live with.
I think I'm a very decent person,
but I'm also fine,
but thank you.
But there's a part of me that's not good
at certain stuff that makes heather's
life heart right.
And that stuff she's good at putting up
with it to a certain extent.
And then there are things that will
cause it to get even to get bad.
I need to know that that's happened in
order for us to get past it and she
needs to tell me,
hey,
this isn't the normal level of,
you know,
I'm not really frustrated considering
exploding.
Right.
So.
But it sound that come the,
the necessity of us being able to
exchange that information is there and
the fact you know,
it's,
it's so much less charged if we both
know that sort of that process has to
unfold and that is not an infinite
process and we will be on the other side
of it once you know she's conveyed,
which needs to convey and I've let her
know that I've heard.
And again,
the more times you've done this,
the more likely you are confident.
You know what,
this is going to end up.
Okay,
this feels awful right now like we are
fighting in.
This feels awful and right.
We've done this before and actually this
proves to
be necessary because it reset some
things that you know,
just every relationship,
no matter if it's romantic or not,
needs resets on a regular basis.
And so this is,
this is one way that you consider
theatrically reset some important
points.
This is a great lesson for reasonable
people and everybody would aspire to be
reasonable people loose ended up that we
just did three hours but just flew right
by it,
right?
Wow.
So crazy.
It was really fun.
Really fun.
Three hours.